What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over deliver. Hello, and welcome to your second drink of Traveling Salesman.
有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排更好的呢？那就是由Instacart购物者精心挑选并送到你家门口的、在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排。甚至不用离开儿童戏水池就能订购到大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排。无论你的夏天需要什么杂货，Instacart都能满足你。下载Instacart应用程序，享受前三单免运费。服务费、除外条款和条款适用。Instacart，超额交付的杂货。你好，欢迎来到《旅行推销员》的第二杯饮料。
You know, we talked about how much fun it was to shoot this episode because there were all these great new pairings of people that go out on sales calls. And then you and I got a really treat of a storyline. We did. And listen, if you like the Peacock superfan episodes, this is a particularly juicy one. There's lots of fun little tidbits that got added back into the mix. And I wanted to play an audio clip of this fun runner that got added to the top of the Peacock superfan episode. So in this episode, we know that Andy is anxious because all of the Stanford people keep getting let go
你知道，我们谈过拍摄这一集有多开心，因为有这么多很棒的新组合去进行销售拜访。然后你和我得到了一条非常有趣的故事情节。确实。听着，如果你喜欢Peacock的超级粉丝剧集，这一集特别精彩。有很多有趣的小花絮被加回了混合内容中。我想播放一段音频片段，这是加在Peacock超级粉丝剧集开头的一个有趣的小插曲。在这一集中，我们知道安迪很焦虑，因为斯坦福的所有人都不断被解雇
and now it's just down to him and Karen. And I think he feels like only one of them is gonna be able to stay. But also on this day, Dwight is late to the office. So here is like a scene and some talking heads that were added to the top of the episode that we're gonna expand on this storyline of Dwight being late and Andy trying to be a saboteur.
现在只剩下他和凯伦了。我觉得他觉得他们中只有一个人能留下来。但也在这一天，德怀特上班迟到了。所以这里有一些场景和一些谈话头，被加到了剧集的开头，我们将扩展关于德怀特迟到和安迪试图搞破坏的故事情节。
Dwight's still not here? Oh, he's gonna miss out on all the fun. Do we have a message? Yes. What'd you say? A version of what you told me to say. You told him his ass was grass and that I'm the lawnmower. Yep. I just didn't use those words.
德怀特还没来吗？哦，他会错过所有乐趣的。我们有留言吗？有。你说了什么？你让我说的话的一个版本。你告诉他他的屁股是草，而我是割草机。是的。我只是没用那些词。
Well, okay. All right. Just tell him to come in when he's here. All right. Um, have you guys seen Dwight? I really need him for something. Dwight is late. Wow. That's really frustrating for everyone. Not just me. Why? What do you need him for?
好吧，好吧。他到了就让他进来。好的。嗯，你们看到德怀特了吗？我真的有事找他。德怀特迟到了。哇。这对每个人来说都很令人沮丧。不仅仅是我。为什么？你找他干什么？
He has a bag of really important work things that I need for my job. To do my job. So, I think it's too late already. No. Nope. Alright. I'm gonna level with you. There's no bag of important things. That made it up. Thank you. There's no bag of imported things. That made it up.
他有一个装满重要工作物品的袋子，我工作需要。为了做我的工作。所以，我想已经太晚了。不。没有。好吧。我和你说实话。根本没有装重要物品的袋子。那是编出来的。谢谢。没有装进口物品的袋子。那是编出来的。
Punctuality is something I demand from my employees. I need them to show up on time. So when I finally show up, we can get started right away. I remember all of those because there is this runner and it's all in the deleted scenes. And you know, when we broke down this episode, I talk about those scenes and also the driving scenes. There's tons of driving scenes. There is one with Michael and Andy
准时是我对员工的要求。我需要他们准时出现。这样当我最终出现时，我们可以立即开始。我记得所有这些，因为有这个小插曲，而且都在删除的场景里。你知道，当我们分析这一集时，我谈到了那些场景，还有驾驶场景。有很多驾驶场景。有一个是迈克尔和安迪的
where Michael starts doing some impressions and you know, Andy is really sucking up to him. So he starts doing some impressions. And I looked at the shooting draft and I think Ed and Steve improvised some of these impressions, because they're not in the script or the candy bag alts. Let's hear it.
迈克尔开始做一些模仿，你知道，安迪真的在拍他马屁。所以他开始做一些模仿。我看了拍摄草稿，我觉得艾德和史蒂夫即兴发挥了一些模仿，因为剧本或糖果袋备选里没有这些。让我们听听。
You know if you want your laundry done right? I used to work at Abercrombie. So pretty good folder. Like Gap Girls, SNL. Yeah. I'm folding clothes. That was such a good impression. And that's totally what my job was like. You're correct sir.
你知道如果你想把衣服洗好吗？我以前在Abercrombie工作。所以折叠得相当好。像Gap女孩，SNL。是的。我在折叠衣服。那模仿得真好。那完全就是我工作时的样子。你说得对，先生。
Wow. That is a good impression. I'm sorry, did you take Ed McMahon lessons? That's pretty amazing. You have to have an ear for it. No, you've got it. You've got it down pat. Ah, how cool is this? Driving around Just sharing our lives and becoming friends
哇。那模仿得真好。抱歉，你上过艾德·麦克马洪的课吗？那太神奇了。你得有那种天赋。不，你做到了。你掌握得很好。啊，这多酷啊？开车到处走，分享我们的生活，成为朋友。
I'm doing Jan, you know What? Yes, I have been seeing and doing a lot of Jan recently. You are the man now dog Anthony Hopkins Give me another one. I'll take shorts for 200. Ben Kingsley. Give me another. Well, isn't that special?
我在模仿简，你知道吗？是的，我最近一直在见简，也在模仿她。你现在是男人了，伙计。安东尼·霍普金斯。再给我来一个。我选短裤，200分。本·金斯利。再给我来一个。嗯，那不是很特别吗？
Isn't that special? Isn't that special? Kanye West. What? Yes. You are bad in a thousand. That's ridiculous. I think when they got to the part where he's like, give me another one,
那不是很特别吗？那不是很特别吗？坎耶·韦斯特。什么？是的。你坏了一千次。那太荒谬了。我想当他们说到他像那样说“再给我来一个”的时候，
give me another one, they just started riffing. I think you're right. You know, I was also happy to see that they added back so much of Pam's art contest storyline in the Peacock episode. There's this really sweet scene where she gets the phone call that she won the contest. She's at work and the camera is kind of close on her.
再给我来一个，他们就开始即兴发挥了。我想你是对的。你知道，我也很高兴看到他们在Peacock剧集中加回了这么多帕姆的艺术比赛故事情节。有一个非常甜蜜的场景，她接到电话说她赢了比赛。她在工作，摄像机离她很近。
She gets the news and then the camera widens out. She's all excited to share and the whole bullpen is empty. So she has to just celebrate with the camera crew. But I'm really glad it got added back because I think it makes it even sweeter at the end when Jim acknowledges it. No, I love that. Well, we all know why Dwight was late to work. It's because he drove some tax forms to New York for Angela. But you know, they won't admit it because they don't want people to know about their relationship.
她得到了消息，然后摄像机拉远了。她很兴奋地想分享，但整个办公区空无一人。所以她只能和摄制组一起庆祝。但我真的很高兴它被加了回来，因为我觉得当吉姆承认这一点时，结尾会更甜蜜。不，我喜欢那个。好吧，我们都知道德怀特为什么上班迟到。因为他开车给安吉拉送了一些税表到纽约。但你知道，他们不会承认的，因为他们不想让人们知道他们的关系。
Well, we got a fan theory from Brittany W. who wrote in and said, I'm convinced Angela purposely forgot the tax forms to make Dwight take them to New York as an act of heroic love for her. That's 100% something Angela Martin would do. Let's discuss. Wow. I mean, that's very plotting. But very plausible.
好吧，我们收到了布列塔尼·W的一条粉丝理论，她写道，我确信安吉拉故意忘了税表，让德怀特把它们带到纽约，作为她英雄般爱情的一种行为。那百分之百是安吉拉·马丁会做的事。让我们讨论一下。哇。我的意思是，那非常有心计。但非常可信。
I mean. Except she's so genuinely stressed in the episode. She's so stressed out. And I mean, they wanted me for my portrayal of it to be like, like a nail biter, you know? Like is he going to make it back in time? But you know, Brittany, that might have turned her on. I don't know. I don't know.
我的意思是。除了她在这一集中真的很紧张。她太紧张了。我的意思是，他们希望我表现得像，像咬指甲一样，你知道吗？就像他能及时赶回来吗？但你知道，布列塔尼，那可能让她兴奋了。我不知道。我不知道。
I think she didn't do it on purpose, also because she takes such pride in her work. Yeah. And she does not like it when people mess up. So that's the other thing. But I do believe that Angela would create hoops for a lover to jump through. To prove themselves. I do buy that. Same. Well, finally lady, this episode of the podcast really went in an interesting direction near the end. When
我觉得她不是故意的，也因为她对自己的工作感到非常自豪。是的。而且她不喜欢别人搞砸。所以这是另一回事。但我确实相信安吉拉会为爱人设置障碍让他们去跳。为了证明他们自己。我确实相信这一点。我也是。好吧，最后女士，这一集的播客在结尾处真的走向了一个有趣的方向。当你
you told me all about staged funerals. Yes. We got a lot of mail. Christine S said, when you went off the rails talking about specialized funerals and Marjorie and Larry, I laughed so hard I nearly wet myself. Then bringing it full circle to laundry and betrayal. I may have rewound and listened to that part several times. And Allie said, I just want you to know that I had to pull over because I was laughing so hard when Angela said, fuck you, Larry. And Sean Aziz said, I have never laughed so hard at a podcast as I did last night driving home when you guys were
告诉我所有关于舞台葬礼的事情时。是的。我们收到了很多邮件。克里斯汀·S说，当你谈论专门的葬礼以及玛乔丽和拉里时，我笑得太厉害了，差点尿裤子。然后回到洗衣和背叛的话题。我可能倒回去听了好几次那部分。艾莉说，我只是想让你知道，当安吉拉说“去你的，拉里”时，我笑得太厉害了，不得不把车停在路边。肖恩·阿齐兹说，我昨晚开车回家时，听你们谈论
talking about funeral poses. I spit my tea all over my steering wheel and windshield. Thanks for the laughs. Oh, lady, I remember that moment. We were recording from home. It was during the pandemic. That whole conversation that we had and the whole bit that we did about Larry and Marjorie,
葬礼姿势时，从来没有像那样在听播客时笑得那么厉害。我把茶喷得满方向盘和挡风玻璃都是。谢谢你们带来的欢笑。哦，女士，我记得那一刻。我们是在家里录音的。那是在疫情期间。我们进行的整个对话，以及我们关于拉里和玛乔丽的整个段子，
it was such a release. It felt so good to laugh so hard. Oh my gosh. I still think it could be like a made for TV movie. Oh, well, listen, everyone, thanks for your letters. That's all we've got. Please enjoy this breakdown of traveling salesmen. Welcome to traveling salesmen.
那真是一种释放。笑得那么开心感觉真好。哦，天哪。我仍然认为它可以拍成一部电视电影。哦，好吧，听着，大家，谢谢你们的来信。这就是我们所有的内容了。请享受这次对《旅行推销员》的分析。欢迎来到《旅行推销员》。
What's that? Welcome to the rock. What are you doing? Sean Conner. Thank you. One more. Some things in here don't react so well to bullets. Yep. One more. Some things in here don't react so well to bullets. Yep.
那是什么？欢迎来到岩石岛。你在做什么？肖恩·康纳利。谢谢。再来一个。这里面有些东西对子弹反应不太好。是的。再来一个。这里面有些东西对子弹反应不太好。是的。
One more. He thinks you're a buckaroo. All right. That's enough. Okay. That's enough. Okay. I'm done.
再来一个。他以为你是牛仔。好了。够了。好吧。够了。好吧。我做完了。
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将分析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。
Hi everybody. So if you see a photo of us podcasting, I am now in my husband's closet. Those are not my baseball hats. That is his baseball hat collection. I like to wear baseball hats. You do. You, you are sort of like a baseball hat family. I feel like all of your, all of your family loves baseball hats. Oh lady, one Christmas we were trying to find a family photo that we could put on our Christmas card and I couldn't find one where one of us wasn't wearing a hat. And so we decided to make it a bit and we did a collage of just a baseball hat Christmas card.
大家好。所以如果你看到一张我们录播客的照片，我现在在我丈夫的衣橱里。那些不是我的棒球帽。那是他的棒球帽收藏。我喜欢戴棒球帽。你确实喜欢。你，你有点像一个棒球帽家庭。我觉得你们所有的，你们所有的家人都喜欢棒球帽。哦，女士，有一个圣诞节，我们试图找一张可以放在圣诞卡上的全家福，但我找不到一张我们中没有人戴帽子的照片。所以我们决定把它变成一个梗，我们做了一个全是棒球帽的圣诞卡拼贴画。
My mother-in-law was mortified. Mortified. She's like, why are you all in hats? Yes, baseball hats for your formal Christmas card. But yeah, it was like an inside joke. We're a hat family. We would fit in very well in Josh's closet, I guess is what I'm saying. I think you would.
我婆婆被吓坏了。吓坏了。她说，为什么你们都戴着帽子？是的，正式圣诞卡上戴着棒球帽。但是的，这就像一个内部笑话。我们是一个帽子家庭。我想我们很适合待在乔什的衣橱里。我想你会的。
By the way, side note, your Christmas cards are always awesome. My favorite, and I have it hanging up in the kitchen still, is the one where you guys are all holding Sunny, your cat. Oh yes, that was another fun collage. We had a good time with that. Lee has Sonny on his head. I'm holding Sonny upside down. It was a good one. Thanks lady. You guys have a floppy cat and floppy cats are so great in photos. My
顺便说一句，题外话，你们的圣诞卡总是很棒。我最喜欢的一张，我现在还挂在厨房里，是你们所有人抱着桑尼，你们的猫的那张。哦，是的，那是另一个有趣的拼贴画。我们玩得很开心。李把桑尼放在头上。我把桑尼倒着抱。那是一张好照片。谢谢你，女士。你们有一只软绵绵的猫，软绵绵的猫在照片里太棒了。我的
cats would have like shredded our heads like if we tried that. Okay okay so here we go. What are we doing today, Jenna? Today we are talking about season three, episode 12, traveling salesmen. Oh, it's so good. It's so good. I rewatched this one and The Return with my kids. We all snuggled up in bed and watched them. They were laughing hysterically. Well Angela, it's a good thing you watched those together. I did too, because they were actually created to be kind of one big episode to be watched together. And that is why they were written by three writers, Mike Schurr, Lee Eisenberg, and Gene
猫如果我们要尝试那样做，会把我们的头抓烂的。好吧，好吧，那么我们开始吧。我们今天要做什么，珍娜？今天我们要谈论第三季第12集，《旅行推销员》。哦，太棒了。太棒了。我和我的孩子们重温了这一集和《回归》。我们都蜷缩在床上看了。他们笑得歇斯底里。好吧，安吉拉，你们一起看这些真是太好了。我也看了，因为它们实际上被创作出来作为一集大剧集一起观看。这就是为什么它们由三位编剧撰写，迈克·舒尔，李·艾森伯格和吉恩·
Stupnitsky. And both of those episodes were directed by Greg Daniels. All right, Jen, well, why don't you hit us with a summary? All right, Jen, well, why don't you hit us with a summary? All right. So in Traveling Salesman, because that's the episode we're covering today, Dwight covers for Angela after she misses an important deadline. The sales team all pair up for sales calls. But at the same time, Angela uncharacteristically invites Pam to coffee and then discusses her love life in code. But then discusses her love life.
斯图普尼茨基。这两集都由格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导。好了，简，你为什么不给我们一个总结呢？好了，简，你为什么不给我们一个总结呢？好的。所以在《旅行推销员》中，因为这是我们今天讨论的剧集，德怀特在安吉拉错过重要截止日期后为她掩护。销售团队都配对进行销售拜访。但与此同时，安吉拉一反常态地邀请帕姆喝咖啡，然后用暗语讨论她的爱情生活。但然后讨论她的爱情生活。
In code, but she discusses her love life. And then upon the return of the sales team, Michael learns that Dwight went to corporate behind his back. He doesn't know why. Dwight quits Dunder Mifflin. Yes! And then Karen finds out that Jim once had a thing for Pam. That's a lot of stuff.
用暗语，但她讨论了她的爱情生活。然后销售团队回来后，迈克尔得知德怀特背着他去了公司。他不知道为什么。德怀特辞职了。是的！然后凯伦发现吉姆曾经对帕姆有意思。那有很多事情。
That's a lot of stuff. Phyllis, man, she spilled the beans. I know, Phyllis. Phyllis. Okay, we'll get to that. We'll get to that. I bet you have some really good fast facts. Well, you know I do because you know that we got something.
那有很多事情。菲利斯，天哪，她泄露了秘密。我知道，菲利斯。菲利斯。好吧，我们会谈到的。我们会谈到的。我打赌你有一些非常好的速记事实。好吧，你知道我有，因为你知道我们有东西。
We did. All right, so here's what we got. All right, fast fact number one. Like I said, both this and the next episode, The Return, were written and treated like one big episode. They were both directed by Greg Daniels. What did we do, Ange? Tell everybody what we did.
我们确实有。好吧，这是我们得到的。好吧，速记事实第一条。就像我说的，这一集和下一集《回归》都是作为一集大剧集来写和对待的。它们都由格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导。我们做了什么，安吉？告诉大家我们做了什么。
We reached out to Greg and he sent in audio clips and they are fantastic. And now Jen and I want him to send an audio clips every single week. Yes. His audio clips are so good. You guys were giddy about them. So the first thing we asked him was what was the inspiration for this episode? And here's what he had to say. Traveling salesman and The Return is a little two episode arc that we did as part of the working out of the merger
我们联系了格雷格，他发来了音频片段，它们太棒了。现在简和我想让他每周都发音频片段。是的。他的音频片段太好了。你们对它们感到头晕目眩。所以我们问他的第一件事是这一集的灵感是什么？这就是他要说的。《旅行推销员》和《回归》是我们作为合并工作的一部分所做的两集弧线故事
of the two branches stories. Andy was always conceived in Gay Witch Hunt to be the Stanford version of Dwight. So it was natural that they butt heads when the branches merged. And we liked the idea that Dwight as the hometown favorite gets to have a really strong and romantic arc here. You see a very noble side of him protecting the woman that he loves.
两个分支的故事。安迪在《同性恋女巫狩猎》中一直被构思为德怀特的斯坦福版本。所以当分支合并时，他们发生冲突是很自然的。我们喜欢德怀特作为家乡宠儿在这里有一个非常强大和浪漫的弧线。你看到了他非常高尚的一面，保护着他所爱的女人。
And I think one of the reasons we made it two episodes was it didn't feel real to me or earned to have him leave and come back in only one episode. So it just felt a lot better to spread it out over two. And another part about that storyline was that it was pairings. And, you know, a writing exercise that I often did with the writers was I'd have them try and come up with pairings of characters that we hadn't had scenes together before. And so this entire episode was fun pairings like Ryan and Stanley, or Phyllis and Karen. And of course, Angela and Pam, who have a great emotional storyline where they really are kind of growing as friends. And it was really cool to see Jim and Dwight too and see their backstory. And then the other thing
我想我们把它做成两集的原因之一是，让他离开并在仅仅一集里回来对我来说感觉不真实或不值得。所以把它分散在两集里感觉好多了。关于那个故事情节的另一部分是配对。而且，你知道，我经常和编剧们做的一个写作练习是，我会让他们尝试想出我们以前没有在一起演过戏的角色配对。所以整集都是有趣的配对，比如瑞安和斯坦利，或者菲利斯和凯伦。当然还有安吉拉和帕姆，她们有一个很棒的情感故事情节，她们真的在某种程度上作为朋友成长。看到吉姆和德怀特也很有趣，看到他们的背景故事。然后另一件事
about Traveling Salesman was we used in the client, we used being good at sales to make Michael more likable. And right, you know, in Traveling Salesman, you see a whole bunch of different characters and how they are as salespeople. And you see how great Jim and Dwight work together. And Michael being like a straight man for Andy, who's just terrible. And so it kind of helps distinguish the more likeable original Dwight versus the more sinister, scheming, you know, new Dwight.
关于《旅行推销员》的是，我们在《客户》中使用了擅长销售来让迈克尔更讨人喜欢。而且，你知道，在《旅行推销员》中，你看到了很多不同的角色以及他们作为销售人员的样子。你看到了吉姆和德怀特合作得有多好。迈克尔就像安迪的直男，安迪简直太糟糕了。所以这有助于区分更讨人喜欢的原始德怀特和更阴险、更狡猾的，你知道，新德怀特。
Keep talking. Talk forever, Greg. Greg, talk forever. It's so fascinating. I love that not only were there these new pairings of characters but also of writers. It's just so interesting. Yes, yes, Ange. And so much comes out in this episode when you put these different people together for the first time really. Yeah. So you guys, I don't know if we need to start some sort of a petition but we really want to create a new feature of the show called inspiration with Greg.
继续说。永远说下去，格雷格。格雷格，永远说下去。这太迷人了。我喜欢不仅有这些新的角色配对，还有编剧的配对。这太有趣了。是的，是的，安吉。当你第一次把这些不同的人放在一起时，这一集里真的有很多东西显露出来。是的。所以你们，我不知道我们是否需要发起某种请愿，但我们真的想创造一个名为“格雷格的灵感”的新节目特色。
And he will send us an audio clip of the inspiration behind every episode. And there's like piano music. Greg will tell us the inspiration and then Kent tells us the nuts and bolts of how he made that inspiration happen. Greg is listening right now and is like, ladies, what are you signing me up for? Exactly. What is Fast Fact number two? Well, Angela, speaking of Kentopedia, Fast Fact number two is called Locations, Locations, Locations.
他会给我们发送每一集背后的灵感的音频片段。而且有钢琴音乐。格雷格会告诉我们灵感，然后肯特告诉我们他是如何让那个灵感实现的细节。格雷格现在正在听，心想，女士们，你们在让我签什么？正是如此。速记事实第二条是什么？好吧，安吉拉，说到肯特百科，速记事实第二条叫做“地点，地点，地点”。
So for this episode, because we actually shot it in conjunction with the return, we did something called crossboarding. It's a little lingo that they use in the biz. Lingo alert! Show this lingo alert! So crossboarding is when you shoot two episodes at once. We normally shot one episode each week, but we shot these episodes over a 10 day period
所以对于这一集，因为我们实际上是和《回归》一起拍摄的，我们做了一些叫做“交叉拍摄”的事情。这是他们在行业中使用的一点行话。行话警报！展示这个行话警报！所以交叉拍摄是指你同时拍摄两集。我们通常每周拍摄一集，但我们在10天的时间里拍摄了这些剧集
from October 16th, 2006 to October 27th, 2006. And the main reason for this was because of locations. We just had a lot of places to go in these two episodes and having the flexibility to shoot it over a two week period was really helpful. Yes, and they would also do a thing, you guys. They call it shooting out a location. So for example, every scene that happened in that coffee shop,
从2006年10月16日到2006年10月27日。主要原因是地点。我们在这两集里有很多地方要去，有灵活性在两周的时间里拍摄非常有帮助。是的，他们还会做一件事，你们。他们称之为“拍完一个地点”。所以例如，发生在那个咖啡店的每一个场景，
they would film in one day. And then they could close out that location. They don't have to pay for that location for multiple days. So sometimes when you cross-bord, it's a great way to save money because you can shoot out a location. They don't have to pay for that location for multiple days. So sometimes when you cross board, it's a great way to save money because you can shoot out a location. Yes. Have we bored you to tears with a little behind the scenes lingo? Lingo alert, shoot out a location. So since you brought up the coffee shop, Angela, we had a fan question from Brianna Kernan, coffee shop Angela we had a fan question from Brianna Kernan, Harshita Verma and Molly Ottawa. Did Pam and Angela go to the same coffee shop that Jim and Karen end up going to later and is the coffee shop location the same one used in later episodes? Yes, yes and yes. Yes and yes and here's
他们会在一天内拍完。然后他们就可以关闭那个地点。他们不必为那个地点支付多天的费用。所以有时当你交叉拍摄时，这是一个省钱的好方法，因为你可以拍完一个地点。他们不必为那个地点支付多天的费用。所以有时当你交叉拍摄时，这是一个省钱的好方法，因为你可以拍完一个地点。是的。我们用一点幕后行话让你感到无聊了吗？行话警报，拍完一个地点。所以既然你提到了咖啡店，安吉拉，我们收到了布里安娜·科南、哈什塔·维尔马和莫莉·渥太华的粉丝提问。帕姆和安吉拉去的是吉姆和凯伦后来去的同一个咖啡店吗？咖啡店地点是后来剧集中使用的同一个吗？是的，是的，是的。是的，是的，这里有一个
a little tidbit Jenna I don't know if you remember. That coffee shop was next door to the place we filmed the tattoo parlor scene. What? Yes, in an upcoming episode with Andy, that tattoo parlor was next to the coffee shop. It must be some little strip mall that Ken just had good favor with. So he was like, okay, we'll take that. We'll take that. Well, here's what Kent told me.
小花絮，简，我不知道你是否记得。那个咖啡店就在我们拍摄纹身店场景的地方隔壁。什么？是的，在即将到来的一集安迪的剧集中，那个纹身店就在咖啡店旁边。那一定是一个肯特有好感的小购物中心。所以他就像，好吧，我们要那个。我们要那个。好吧，这是肯特告诉我的。
He said the coffee shop was a real location. We filmed at a place called Java Groove Coffee. It was on Victory Boulevard in Van Nuys. Yes. However, it has been closed and replaced by a printing company. So I'm sorry if you come to LA you cannot get a cup of coffee anymore at Java Groove Coffee. Well we'll have to find out if they can get a tattoo next door still. Yes, perhaps. What a fun office set tour that would be. You could go see the outside
他说咖啡店是一个真实的地点。我们在一个叫Java Groove Coffee的地方拍摄。它在范奈斯的胜利大道上。是的。然而，它已经关闭并被一家印刷公司取代了。所以如果你来洛杉矶，很抱歉你不能再在Java Groove Coffee喝到咖啡了。好吧，我们得看看他们是否还能在隔壁纹身。是的，也许吧。那将是一个多么有趣的办公室场景之旅啊。你可以去看看
of Dunder Mifflin, grab a cup of coffee and get a tattoo. I mean if you're a die-hard fan, right? cup of coffee and get a tattoo. I mean, if you're a diehard fan, right? Yep. But now you can just get something printed and then get a tattoo. All right. Well, I am not done talking about fast fact number two, Angela. Oh, I'm sorry. More locations. We have so many more locations. This is a question from Kylan Hadley and Jordan Simpson. Were all the sets that the salesman traveled to local office buildings or were they built in the warehouse set like the fancy Stanford branch was. All right, are you ready? Mm-hmm. They were not a set, they
邓德·米夫林的外面，喝杯咖啡，纹个身。我的意思是，如果你是一个铁杆粉丝，对吧？喝杯咖啡，纹个身。我的意思是，如果你是一个铁杆粉丝，对吧？是的。但现在你只能打印点东西，然后纹个身。好吧。好吧，我还没说完速记事实第二条，安吉拉。哦，抱歉。更多地点。我们还有更多地点。这是凯兰·哈德利和乔丹·辛普森的问题。销售人员去的所有场景都是当地的办公楼，还是像花哨的斯坦福分支那样建在仓库场景里？好吧，准备好了吗？嗯。它们不是场景，它们
were a location, but they were all the same location. Here's what they did. The building where Jim and Dwight are in the parking lot and Dwight's like pumping himself up. That was in Van Nuys. It was at the Panorama Medical Plaza. Plaza St. Louis. Was it at the Plaza? It was at the Plaza. Oh my gosh, that's so St. Louis. Saints. Oh my gosh, I have a St. Louis catch later in the episode, but that's that's the first one. Plaza, Plaza. So at the Panorama Medical Plaza, they found a completely vacant floor.
是地点，但它们都是同一个地点。这是他们做的。吉姆和德怀特在停车场，德怀特在给自己打气的那个建筑。那是在范奈斯。它在全景医疗广场。圣路易斯广场。是在广场吗？它在广场。哦，天哪，那太圣路易斯了。圣徒。哦，天哪，我这一集后面有一个圣路易斯的梗，但那是第一个。广场，广场。所以在全景医疗广场，他们发现了一个完全空置的楼层。
And they dressed five different spaces to be the various offices that everyone visits. Isn't that amazing? They took one location and made it five different places, but there's more. Oh, more? So you know how we said we shot these two episodes together? In the next episode, the return, at the beginning you see Dwight going around with his resume. Two of those offices were also part of the Panorama Medical Building. That plaza covered a lot of ground, lady. So much plaza.
他们布置了五个不同的空间，作为每个人访问的各种办公室。那不是很神奇吗？他们拿了一个地点，把它变成了五个不同的地方，但还有更多。哦，更多？所以你知道我们说我们一起拍摄了这两集吗？在下一集《回归》中，开头你看到德怀特带着他的简历到处走。那两个办公室也是全景医疗大楼的一部分。那个广场覆盖了很多地方，女士。太多的广场了。
So one thing, the church scenes with Stanley and Ryan, those were filmed at the Panorama Presbyterian Church on Roscoe. So that was another separate location and then there's even staples, but we'll talk about that next week. So many locations! So many! Alright, I think we've covered all the locations. Let's move on to fast fact number three. Another fan question. Okay.
所以有一件事，斯坦利和瑞安的教堂场景，那些是在罗斯科的全景长老会教堂拍摄的。所以那是另一个独立的地点，然后还有史泰博，但我们下周再谈。太多的地点了！太多了！好吧，我想我们已经涵盖了所有的地点。让我们进入速记事实第三条。另一个粉丝提问。好的。
Guys, we love your questions. They are so helpful in structuring the podcast. Thank you. Alright, fan question. Rachel Labish and Rebecca Kelly said, I noticed a weird discrepancy between the Netflix episodes and the DVD episodes. In the DVD episodes, there is a whole subplot about Pam winning an art contest. In the Netflix version of the episode, the whole thing is cut out.
伙计们，我们喜欢你们的问题。它们对构建播客非常有帮助。谢谢。好的。粉丝提问。瑞秋·拉比什和丽贝卡·凯利说，我注意到Netflix剧集和DVD剧集之间有一个奇怪的差异。在DVD剧集中，有一个关于帕姆赢得艺术比赛的完整子情节。在Netflix版本的剧集中，整个事情都被剪掉了。
I haven't been able to find anything online about it. Do you know why this is? Ladies, that is a fantastic question because this whole podcast almost went haywire because Jenna was watching the Netflix episode and I was watching the DVD episode and they're totally different. Angela and I were so confused because we were trying to outline this episode and there were all these scenes that Angela was talking about that I remembered shooting Angela but that weren't in the version I was watching. Yeah.
我在网上找不到任何关于它的信息。你知道为什么吗？女士们，这是一个非常棒的问题，因为整个播客差点失控，因为珍娜在看Netflix版本，而我在看DVD版本，它们完全不同。安吉拉和我非常困惑，因为我们试图概述这一集，安吉拉谈到的所有场景我都记得拍摄过，安吉拉，但它们不在我看的版本里。是的。
So I started digging around and here is what I found out. On March 15th, 2007, NBC aired a repeat of this episode. But they didn't want to air an exact repeat. They wanted to get more viewers. So they called it a new peat. A new peat? You know, when they would run repeats, they wouldn't get as many viewers, which meant fewer ad dollars for commercials, right?
所以我开始挖掘，这就是我发现的。2007年3月15日，NBC播出了这一集的重播。但他们不想播出完全一样的重播。他们想获得更多的观众。所以他们称之为“新重播”。新重播？你知道，当他们重播时，他们不会获得那么多的观众，这意味着广告收入更少，对吧？
Because that's how networks make money. So they thought if we add a new peat where it's mostly the old episode, but then some stuff you've never seen before, maybe it would up the viewership. And that's why there are now like these two different versions of this episode living out in the world because of somebody in marketing at NBC came
因为这就是电视网赚钱的方式。所以他们想，如果我们增加一个新重播，大部分是旧剧集，但有一些你从未见过的内容，也许它会提高收视率。这就是为什么现在世界上存在这两个不同版本的剧集，因为NBC市场部的某个人想出了
up with this new Pete idea. I don't think we ever did that again. I think this is our one and only new Pete. Am I right? Well, I guess it happens again in season four. Oh, when Phyllis tells Jim about her house that Bob bought her. It's on the DVD, but it's cut out of the Netflix version. So here's what's on the DVD, but it's cut out of the Netflix version. So here's what's on the DVD.
这个新重播的想法。我不认为我们再那样做过。我想这是我们唯一的一次新重播。我说得对吗？好吧，我想它在第四季又发生了。哦，当菲利斯告诉吉姆关于鲍勃给她买的房子时。它在DVD上，但被从Netflix版本中剪掉了。所以这是DVD上的内容，但被从Netflix版本中剪掉了。所以这是DVD上的内容。
First of all, Traveling Salesman and The Return are one episode on the DVD. They're not two episodes. They're one like supersized huge episode. Crazy, right? Crazy. But in The Traveling Salesman, these are the scenes you missed if you watched it on Netflix. Pam gets a phone call that a watercolor she made won a sixth grade elementary school art
首先，在DVD上，《旅行推销员》和《回归》是一集。它们不是两集。它们是一集像超大号的巨大剧集。疯狂，对吧？疯狂。但在《旅行推销员》中，如果你在Netflix上观看，这些是你错过的场景。帕姆接到一个电话，说她做的一幅水彩画赢得了六年级小学艺术
contest. I remember shooting it. These sixth graders picked your art. You were really excited. You won $100. You were really excited to tell Kevin about it. Kevin's like, yeah, well, I won $400 betting on a Celtics game. And you were like, OK, thanks for that, Kevin.
比赛。我记得拍摄它。这些六年级学生选了你的艺术作品。你真的很兴奋。你赢了100美元。你真的很兴奋告诉凯文这件事。凯文说，是的，好吧，我赌凯尔特人队的比赛赢了400美元。然后你说，好的，谢谢你，凯文。
And then she tells Angela, Pam is just desperate to tell someone that her art won. And no one's in the office. They're all out on a sales call. So she pops up over the partition. Jenna, we have one of those classic over the partition Angela and Pam scenes. And she tells Angela, and Angela has all this good favor in her heart towards Pam right now.
然后她告诉安吉拉，帕姆只是迫切想告诉某人她的艺术作品赢了。办公室里没人。他们都出去进行销售拜访了。所以她从隔板上探出头来。珍娜，我们有那些经典的隔板上的安吉拉和帕姆场景之一。她告诉安吉拉，安吉拉现在对帕姆心存好感。
You know, they've gone and got coffee, they've bonded, and so Angela goes, congratulations! And then she says, I really like having these little moments with you." And then she offers Pam, one of her kittens, Sprinkles has had kittens, and she offers Pam the dominant male named Ash. And Pam clearly does not want this cat. She makes up excuses. She's like, oh, you know, my landlord, it's just, I, it's a thing and you know, it'd be, I don't know. And Angela is like
你知道，她们去喝了咖啡，她们建立了联系，所以安吉拉说，恭喜！然后她说，我真的很喜欢和你在一起的这些小时刻。然后她给帕姆提供了她的一只小猫，Sprinkles生了小猫，她给帕姆提供了那个叫Ash的雄性小猫。帕姆显然不想要这只猫。她编造借口。她说，哦，你知道，我的房东，这只是，这是一回事，你知道，这会是，我不知道。安吉拉就像
You she instantly goes back to being just this cold snarky person to Pam. That's it their friendships over It was so fleeting and then lastly when Jim finally comes back from his sales call Pam is so excited to tell him and he's on his way out to have coffee with Karen and Pam's like Jim and he starts talking to her about it and Karen's like, um, we're going to get coffee. So it's this awkward moment. I remember shooting all of that. Here's the other thing I found really interesting. So in the opening scene of the Netflix version, it's Harvey, the computer, right? Yeah. Talking to Jim. That's in the deleted scenes on the DVD. That's not even in the episode. Oh, so I, because I was wondering, well, what did they cut out of the episode in order to make room for Pam's art contest? So there
她立刻变回了那个对帕姆冷漠刻薄的人。就是这样，她们的友谊结束了。它是如此短暂，最后，当吉姆终于从销售拜访回来时，帕姆非常兴奋地告诉他，他正要出去和凯伦喝咖啡，帕姆说，吉姆，他开始和她谈论这件事，凯伦说，嗯，我们要去喝咖啡。所以这是一个尴尬的时刻。我记得拍摄了所有这些。这是我发现的另一件非常有趣的事情。所以在Netflix版本的开场场景中，是哈维，那台电脑，对吧？是的。和吉姆说话。那是在DVD的删除场景里。那甚至不在剧集里。哦，所以我，因为我在想，好吧，为了给帕姆的艺术比赛腾出空间，他们从剧集中剪掉了什么？所以一定有
must be things, when they aired this on NBC, there must be things missing. In the deleted scenes on the DVD, there's a lot of extra scenes in the cars driving. Yeah. Lots of extra driving scenes. And then there's this Harvey the talking computer that's a deleted scene. Wow.
东西，当他们在NBC播出这个时，一定有东西丢失了。在DVD的删除场景里，有很多额外的开车场景。是的。很多额外的驾驶场景。然后还有这个哈维，那台会说话的电脑，是一个删除的场景。哇。
So there you go. We are going to be following along the Netflix airing, because that way our time codes will match up. But that's what you will get if you go to the DVDs. I love it. I love it. I feel like I'm really happy with all of that. I think we should take a break and then come back and break down the episode. Sounds great. This is an ad by BetterHelp.
所以就是这样。我们将跟随Netflix的播出，因为这样我们的时间码就会匹配。但如果你去买DVD，你就会得到这些。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。我觉得我对所有这些都很满意。我想我们应该休息一下，然后回来分析这一集。听起来不错。这是BetterHelp的一则广告。
You know, it feels like nowadays there's advice for just about everything. It's like, do you write in your journal? Do you do, I don't know, cleanses or the cold plunge or, you know, what helps you get through the day? What helps you get through stressful moments? For me, it's talking it out. Well, there can be a lot of information overload about mental health and wellness, and it can be a struggle to know what's true and what actions to take these days. So, you might think about using a trusted resource and talking to live therapists through better help.
你知道，感觉现在几乎每件事都有建议。就像，你写日记吗？你做，我不知道，排毒，或者冷水浴，或者，你知道，什么能帮你度过这一天？什么能帮你度过压力时刻？对我来说，是说出来。嗯，关于心理健康和健康的信息可能太多了，很难知道什么是真的，以及这些天该采取什么行动。所以，你可能会考虑使用一个值得信赖的资源，并通过BetterHelp与现场治疗师交谈。
It has an App Store rating of 4.9 out of five based on over 1.7 million client reviews. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better help
它在应用商店的评分为4.9分（满分5分），基于超过170万条客户评论。作为世界上最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp可以提供接触具有各种专业知识的心理健康专业人员的机会。通过BetterHelp说出来。我们的听众在betterhelp.com/officeladies首次订购可享受10%的折扣。那是betterhelp
help.com slash office ladies Hello, it's Lena Dunham I host a podcast called the c-word with my dearest friend and historian of bad behavior Alyssa Bennett what is up? It's a chat show about women whose society is called crazy It's a chat show about women whose society is called crazy. We're going to be rediscovering the stories of women's society dismissed by calling them mad, sad, or just plain bad. Listen to Unfollow the C-Word with Lena Dunham and Alyssa Bennett, available now wherever you get your podcasts.
help.com/officeladies 你好，我是莉娜·邓纳姆，我主持一个播客叫《C-word》，和我最亲爱的朋友、坏行为历史学家艾丽莎·贝内特一起，怎么了？这是一个关于女性的聊天节目，社会称她们为疯子。这是一个关于女性的聊天节目，社会称她们为疯子。我们将重新发现那些被社会通过称她们为疯狂、悲伤或仅仅是坏而忽视的女性的故事。收听莉娜·邓纳姆和艾丽莎·贝内特主持的《Unfollow the C-Word》，现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听。
All right, we're back. Let's dive right in this episode. Michael is really excited to show Jim and Pam his new computer. It's his buddy, his talking friend, Harvey. Oh my gosh. And basically he types into the keyboard and then Harvey says stuff. Yes. And he's made the back of the computer like a face,
好了，我们回来了。让我们直接进入这一集。迈克尔非常兴奋地向吉姆和帕姆展示他的新电脑。这是他的伙伴，他的会说话的朋友，哈维。哦，天哪。基本上他在键盘上打字，然后哈维说一些话。是的。他把电脑背面做成了一张脸，
like he used some Post-it notes. Anyway, Harvey is this talking computer. Well, we got a fan question from Bailey Aspenson, Becky Gemmell, Megan Kiel, Chelsea Lane, and Alyssa Sorensen. Everyone wants to know who is the voice of Harvey. then everyone wants to know who is the voice of Harvey. Oh, that's a great question. Who is it? I recognized it immediately. And did you recognize it, Angela? Oh, no, I didn't.
就像他用了一些便利贴。总之，哈维是这台会说话的电脑。好吧，我们收到了贝利·阿斯彭森、贝基·格梅尔、梅根·基尔、切尔西·莱恩和艾丽莎·索伦森的粉丝提问。每个人都想知道哈维的声音是谁。然后每个人都想知道哈维的声音是谁。哦，那是一个很好的问题。是谁？我立刻认出来了。你认出来了吗，安吉拉？哦，不，我没有。
Oh, no. As soon as I heard the voice, I was like, oh, it's Mike Schur. Oh, my gosh. That's such a great catch. So I emailed him, and he was like, yes, it's me. I was Harvey. So he's the one that said, me so horny, me love you, Long Tim. Yes, exactly. And Pam's like, oh, I'd love to meet Long Tim. The way you and John played off Steve in that scene made me laugh so hard because
哦，不。我一听到那个声音，我就想，哦，是迈克·舒尔。哦，天哪。那真是个伟大的发现。所以我给他发了邮件，他说，是的，是我。我是哈维。所以他是那个说“我好饥渴，我爱你，Long Tim”的人。是的，正是如此。帕姆说，哦，我很想见见Long Tim。你和约翰在那个场景中与史蒂夫的互动让我笑得太厉害了，因为
Michael just gets so frustrated that you guys aren't thinking his talking computer is amazing. Well, some people notice that when we cut away to Michael's screen, what he's been typing doesn't quite match with what you've been hearing. That's just because the scene was longer. And we actually did have Harvey say all those lines and we had lines, but then in the editing room they cut some of them out. So the screen was indicative of the scene as written and it got a little trimmed down in the editing room. So that's why his screen doesn't quite match.
迈克尔因为你们觉得他的会说话的电脑不神奇而感到非常沮丧。嗯，有些人注意到当我们切到迈克尔的屏幕时，他打的内容和你听到的不太匹配。那只是因为场景更长。我们实际上确实让哈维说了所有那些台词，我们有台词，但在剪辑室里他们剪掉了一些。所以屏幕是剧本中场景的指示，它在剪辑室里被修剪了一点。所以这就是为什么他的屏幕不太匹配。
Some really good fan catches right away. I know. All right. So now, Angela, we move over to accounting and Kevin tells Angela that corporate did not receive their tax forms but Angela says no no they arrived this morning and he wants you to know how very important this is Angela here's what I wrote down when I watched this scene what WTF is up with your hair. Why do you have a flower of hair on the back of your head? Guys, I'm going to I took a picture and I'm going to post it because it's insanity.
一些非常好的粉丝发现。我知道。好吧。所以现在，安吉拉，我们转到会计部，凯文告诉安吉拉公司没有收到他们的税表，但安吉拉说不不，它们今天早上到了，他想让你知道这有多重要，安吉拉，这是我观看这个场景时写下的，你的头发到底是怎么回事。为什么你的后脑勺上有一朵头发花？伙计们，我要，我拍了一张照片，我要发出来，因为它太疯狂了。
What is happening? When we got the script, Kim Ferry and I started talking Kim is who did our hair and we were like, you know, Angela is happy in this episode. Now, she starts out in the morning a little worried, right? Did Dwight make it? Is everything going to be okay? But she's a lady in love and her man has done this amazingly gallant thing for her. And I feel like she's sort of dressing the part of like this lady in love. She's
发生了什么？当我们拿到剧本时，金·费里和我开始谈论，金是做我们头发的人，我们就像，你知道，安吉拉在这一集中很开心。现在，她早上开始时有点担心，对吧？德怀特赶上了吗？一切都会好吗？但她是一个恋爱中的女士，她的男人为她做了这件令人惊叹的英勇之事。我觉得她有点像在打扮成这个恋爱中的女士。她
wearing her Janet Jackson rhythm nation mini short sleeve jacket. That's made a callback. And she did a little something extra fancy with her hair. Kim and I just thought maybe she's just she's taken it up a notch. Yeah, she turned her hair into a pinwheel flower. And clearly she has eight arms and multiple mirrors. Because how do you do that to the back of your head? Well, when I saw that hair, all I could think about was, oh my gosh, she couldn't lay down during her breaks. Because sometimes at lunch, I would want to lay back
穿着她的珍妮·杰克逊《节奏国度》迷你短袖夹克。那是一个回调。而且她在头发上做了一些额外花哨的事情。金和我只是觉得也许她只是，她把它提升了一个档次。是的，她把她的头发变成了一个风车花。而且显然她有八只手臂和多面镜子。因为你怎么能对你的后脑勺做那种事？嗯，当我看到那头发时，我能想到的只有，哦，天哪，她在休息时不能躺下。因为有时在午餐时，我想躺下
after I eat, maybe snooze it out, because we would get up real early. Sometimes I need a maybe snooze it out, because we would get up real early. Sometimes I need a little snooze at lunch, but you couldn't do that that week, I guess. Couldn't lay on that. That would be so uncomfortable. I couldn't even lean back on a chair, lady. I couldn't even recline in any way.
吃完饭后，也许打个盹，因为我们起得很早。有时我需要也许打个盹，因为我们起得很早。有时我需要午餐时小睡一下，但我想那一周你做不到。不能躺在那上面。那会很不舒服。我甚至不能靠在椅子上，女士。我甚至不能以任何方式斜靠。
Guys, check it out. You don't have to look hard. It's insane. It's also amazing. We had a lot of people write in Julia Lee Bethany Devish Kaylee waiting Anita Prasad They all said Angela's hair looks incredible in this episode Thank you. Thank you very much And now we're gonna come up onto this talking head that Rashida actually mentioned when she was a guest on Benihana,
伙计们，去看看吧。你不需要费力去看。这太疯狂了。这也太神奇了。我们有很多写信进来的人，朱莉娅·李、贝瑟尼·德维什、凯莉·韦廷、安妮塔·普拉萨德，他们都说安吉拉的头发在这一集中看起来不可思议。谢谢。非常感谢。现在我们要谈到拉什达在做客《本尼哈纳》时提到的那个谈话头，
where Andy talks about him and Karen being the last two left standing, right? And Andy says he's not going to be one of the kids touring Willy Wonka's factory. He will not fall into the Chocolate River. I loved that reference. I loved it too, but all I could think about Jenna is that he does fall into the lake. When? At beach games. Totally forgot that. He falls into the lake. He's in a giant sumo suit and he floats on by and I couldn't help but think what an amazing like callback to the Willy Wonka River thing. I don't know. I thought that was kind of fun. Oh my God. Yeah, I totally. Yes. I'm so sorry. It's all coming back to me. We'll get to it when
安迪说他和凯伦是最后剩下的两个人，对吧？安迪说他可不想成为参观威利·旺卡工厂的孩子之一。他绝不会掉进巧克力河里。我喜欢这个梗。我也喜欢，但杰娜，我当时满脑子想的都是他确实掉进湖里了。什么时候？在海滩运动会的时候。完全忘了。他掉进湖里了。他穿着巨大的相扑服，漂浮着经过，我忍不住想，这真是对威利·旺卡巧克力河情节的绝妙呼应。我不知道，我觉得这挺有趣的。天哪。是的，我完全。是的。真抱歉。我想起来了。我们讲到海滩运动会的时候会提到的。但没错，艾德慢慢漂走的样子。我现在记得太清楚了。那么安吉拉，现在你站在前台，正在拿软糖吃，德怀特进来了。太贴心了。他告诉你税表已经送到了。你们在用暗语交谈，但帕姆当然全看在眼里。然后当你走开时，你说，我不想要这些，就把软糖留下了。我们有个粉丝提问。好的。艾莉·乔·希金博瑟姆问，安吉拉拿走软糖后对帕姆说的那句“我不想要这些”是即兴发挥的吗？
we talk about beach games. But yes, Ed slowly floating away. I remember it now so clearly. So Angela, now you're standing at reception, you're getting yourself some jelly beans, and Dwight comes in. It's so sweet. He lets you know the tax forms have been delivered. You guys are kind of talking in code, but of course Pam is clocking it all. And then as you walk away, you say, I don't want these, and you leave the jelly beans. We had a fan question. Okay. Allie Jo Higginbotham says, did Angela improv that line,
是的，确实是。格雷格在那场戏里给我的指示是，我非常急于和德怀特交谈，想知道一切是否顺利，但我必须给自己找点事做。比如，我为什么会在前台？所以我决定去翻翻软糖。我当时就想，哦，我就这么做吧。所以我翻着软糖，在整场戏里往手里抓了几颗。然后当德怀特走开时，我手里正好拿着它们。所以我只是
I don't want these to Pam after she took the jelly beans. Yes, yes I did. The note that Greg had given me in that scene is that, I'm so anxious to talk to Dwight to find out that everything went okay, but I had to make some business for myself. Like, why would I be at reception? So I decided to kind of dig in the jelly beans. I just sort of was like, Oh, this is what I'll do. So I was digging in the jelly beans and I put a few in my hand throughout the scene. And then as Dwight walked away, I just had him in my hand. So I just
把它们放在了柜台上，就像小孩子会做的那样。我不喜欢这个。是的，走开了，我手里正好拿着它们。所以我只是把它们放在了柜台上，就像小孩子会做的那样。我不喜欢这个。是的。就这么走开了。这让我们觉得太逗了。他们把这一幕留在了正片里。但我更喜欢的部分是你的表情，杰娜。你的表情，在那一刻对我来说意味深长。
placed him on the countertop like your kid would. I don't like this. Yes, walked away, I just had him in my hand. So I just placed him on the countertop, like your kid would. I don't like this. Yes. Just walked away. And it just tickled us so much. And they left it in. But the part I love even more, Jenna, is your look. Your look of like, it said so much to me in the moment.
那表情仿佛在说，人们总是把水瓶和垃圾留在我的桌子上。一直都是这样。在你留下软糖后，我加了一点戏，但被剪掉了，可能确实应该剪掉，因为那会没完没了。但我会想出各种方法来处理这些软糖。我记得有一次我拿起垃圾桶，用一张纸把它们扫进垃圾桶里，
It said, people leave their water bottles and their trash on my desk. Constantly. All the time. After you would leave the jelly beans, I added a little bit that got cut out and probably it should have been cut out because it just would have gone on forever. But I would find all these various ways to get rid of the jelly beans. So I remember one time I picked up the trash can and I scooched them into the trash can using a piece of paper and
还有一次我拿了张纸巾，用纸巾把它们捡起来。还有一次我想我把它们捡起来放回了软糖罐里。我知道我有各种方法处理这些软糖，我玩得很开心。当然，这些都没剪进正片，但这只是我们做的一个有趣的小片段。那么我们现在去会议室吧，安吉拉？哦，好的，因为有人需要递一下塔塔酱。是的，整个销售团队都集合在
another time I like took a tissue and I picked them up with a tissue and Another time I think I picked them up and put them back in the jelly bean container I know I had all these ways that I got rid of these Jelly beans and I had a good time with that. None of them made it in, of course, but it was just kind of like a fun little bit we were doing. So should we move into the conference room now, Angela? Oh yeah, because somebody needs to pass the tarty sauce. Yes, the entire sales team is assembled
会议室里，而德怀特迟到了。安迪真是个讨厌鬼。天哪。在这场戏的开头，迈克尔解释说这是他的梦之队。这是我的梦之销售团队，我们要两两分组去进行销售拜访。我们有个来自霍莉·埃纳森的粉丝提问。霍莉·埃纳森说，菲利斯在迈克尔说完“这是我的梦之队”后立刻擤了鼻涕。
in the conference room and Dwight comes in late. So Andy is such a tool. Oh my gosh. So at the beginning of this scene, Michael explains that this is his dream team. This is my dream sales team and we're going to pair up and go on some sales calls. And we had a fan question from Holly Enerson. Holly Enerson says, Phyllis blows her nose right after Michael says, This is my dream team.
那是剧本写的吗？我也纳闷，因为太精彩了。时机把握得太完美了。太完美了。是的，那是剧本写的。太棒了。这是剧本指示。引用：
Was that scripted? I wondered the same thing because it's brilliant. The timing is so perfect. It's so perfect. Yes, it was scripted. Amazing. Here is the script direction. Quote,
镜头扫过销售团队无聊的脸。菲利斯擤了鼻涕。你们知道吗，伙计们，这是一个小瞬间，因为我看了好几遍。太棒了。菲利斯拿出她的小纸巾。她吸了吸鼻子，然后擤了鼻涕。她时机把握得太完美了，但她开始得有点早，我觉得正是这一点让它看起来如此自然。这真是非常精彩的表演。
The camera pans to bored faces of the sales team. Phyllis blows her nose. And you know, I got a guys, I, this is a little moment because I watched it several times. It's so great. Phyllis gets out her little tissue. She sniffles a little bit and then she blows her nose. Like she times it perfectly but she starts the bit a little early and I think that's what sells making it look so organic. It's really wonderful work.
小细节。菲利斯，天哪，纸巾戏演得真好。所以每个人都配了对。是的，我们有凯伦和菲利斯，瑞安和斯坦利，德怀特和吉姆，还有迈克尔和安迪。现在他们要整天待在车里了。我等不及了。我记得我们在剧本围读会上看到分组时，我就想，哦，这一定会很有趣。嗯，这里有个瑞安的采访镜头让我笑得不行。
Little details. Phyllis, man, with the tissue work. So everyone gets paired up. Yes, we get Karen and Phyllis and Ryan and Stanley, Dwight and Jim and Michael and Andy. Now they're gonna go out and be in cars together all day. I couldn't wait. I remember when we got the script at the table read when I saw like the groupings I was like oh this is gonna be so fun. Well there's a Ryan talking head in here that makes me laugh so hard.
因为你现在在现实生活中就是瑞安。我就是瑞安。我喜欢他说他很荣幸能成为斯坦利的第二选择，在“放弃”之后。在“放弃”之后。斯坦利可以挑选搭档，他的第一反应是“放弃”。他的第二反应是，我想我只能选这孩子了。嗯，我想快速聊聊吉姆的采访镜头。
Because you are now Ryan in real life. I am now Ryan. I love it that he said he's flattered to be Stanley's second choice after PASS. After PASS. Stanley got to pick his partner and his first response was PASS. And his second response was, I guess I'll take the kid. Well, I wanted to talk really quickly about Jim's talking head.
他举起那张德怀特和吉姆的照片，就是那张老照片。因为他们显然一起进行过无数次销售拜访，对吧？这稍微展示了他们的过去，我很喜欢。但在DVD评论音轨里，雷恩说那张照片里他的头发是1991年的。当时他正随一个演艺公司巡演，演《罗密欧与朱丽叶》，
He holds up that photo of Dwight and Jim, like the old photo. Because they clearly have been on a ton of sales calls together, right? And it shows their history a little bit, which I love. But in the DVD commentary, Reign said that his hair in that photo was from 1991. He was on tour with an acting company doing Romeo and Juliet,
他们都留着长长的伊丽莎白时代的头发。他们把那头发PS到了现在的德怀特头上，但保留了那头浓密的头发。我觉得太搞笑了。我喜欢这个细节。我知道。所以现在他们都在停车场。他们分成了小组。他们正要上车出发。迈克尔把德怀特的脏衣服扔给他，这是对“政变”那一集的呼应。我喜欢我们剧集做这种呼应，这一集里有好几个，但这是对“政变”的呼应，现在他让大家围成一圈，要给他们下达指令。
and they all had long Elizabethan hair. And they sort of like photoshopped it onto current Dwight, but they left that big hair. I just thought it was hilarious. I love that detail. I know. So now they're all in the parking lot. They're paired up into their teams. They're about to get in their cars and go. Michael tosses Dwight his dirty laundry which is a callback to the coup. I love it when our show does this and we have a few in this episode but this is a callback to the coup and now he tells them all to circle up and he's going to give them their marching orders.
是的。然后迈克尔说，伙计们，我们去进行销售拜访吧。就像我们在参加《极速前进》一样。大家都说，我们怎么就成《极速前进》了？有奖品吗？他说，不，没有奖品，但我们就是《极速前进》。他还给每个人起了队名。大家都非常困惑。
Yeah. So then Michael says, guys, let's go out on our sales calls. It's like we're the amazing race. And everyone's like, how are we the amazing race? Is there a prize? He's like, no, there's no prize, but we're the Amazing Race. And he keeps gives everybody these team names. And everyone's very confused.
然后迈克尔就沮丧了。他说，去进行你们的销售拜访吧。但我喜欢他提到了《极速前进》。这在当时是一档非常、非常受欢迎的真人秀。我是个超级粉丝。杰娜，我们当时太沉迷了。我记得你和我……我是个超级粉丝。杰娜，我们当时太沉迷了。我记得你和我……
And then Michael just gets frustrated. He's like, just go on your sales call. But I love that he brought up the Amazing Race. This was a really, really popular reality show at the time. And I was a huge fan. Jenna, we were so into it. I remember you and I was a huge fan. Jenna, we were so into it. I remember you and I watching the Amazing Race and then Jenna, do you remember how you and I were like,
我们应该去参加，我们应该一起组队参加《极速前进》。我坚持这么认为，我觉得我们应该去。我觉得我们会表现得很棒。我觉得我们会一团糟。为什么？为什么？因为，因为我觉得你会说，快走，快走。
we should go on, we should be a team on Amazing Race together. I stand by that, I think we should. I think we would have been amazing. I think we would have been a total mess. Why? Why? Because, because I think you would be like, let's go, let's go.
而我会说，我们能休息一下吗？也许喝杯红酒？你会说，好吧。而且，我吃不了那些恶心的东西，女士。我吃不了恶心的东西。嗯，这就是问题所在。我觉得我们俩会有一些同样的弱点。我觉得我们都吃不了恶心的东西。而且可能我们俩在上肢力量方面都不太行，应付不了那些需要把干草捆扔过迷宫之类的任务，
And I'd be like, can we just take a break? Maybe we'll have a glass of wine. You'd be like, yeah. Also, I can't eat any of that gross stuff, lady. I can't eat the gross stuff. Well, this is the problem. I think we would both have some of the same weaknesses. I think we couldn't eat the gross stuff. And maybe neither one of us would have great upper body strength for some of the like things where you have to like toss bales of hay down a maze
或者类似的事情。上肢力量为零怎么样？是的。零。所以也许我们不会成为那么好的团队，但我们会玩得很开心。我觉得我们会玩得很开心的。我觉得我们会经历一次巨大的崩溃，
or something. How about zero upper body strength? Yeah. Zero. So maybe we wouldn't have been such a great team but we would have had fun. I think we would have had fun. I think we would have had one colossal meltdown
然后吵一架，然后我们会哭，然后我们会歇斯底里地大笑。我们看起来像疯子，但我们会玩得很开心的。我告诉你，我们会是很好的电视节目素材。天哪，我们会是很好的电视节目素材。好吧，好吧。嗯，我们确实问过格雷格关于这个《极速前进》的时刻，他是这么说的。和《极速前进》的比较很有趣，因为它是现实。我们是一部基于现实的喜剧。对于剧集的视觉效果来说，尝试引用其他真人秀节目比引用电影要容易得多。
and then a fight and then we would have cried and then we'd laugh hysterically. We look like crazy people, but we would have had fun. I tell you what, we would have been good TV. Oh my God, we would have been great TV. Okay, okay. Well, we actually asked Greg about this amazing race moment and here's what he had to say. The comparison to amazing race was fun because it's a reality. We were a reality based comedy show. It was a lot easier for the visual look of the show to be able to try and do references to other reality shows rather than movies, for instance.
所以，在“酒醉巡游”里有个《泰坦尼克号》的梗，但我觉得它在视觉上不如这里的《极速前进》梗好用。是的，这对我来说完全说得通。我觉得迈克尔是流行文化、电视和电影的超级粉丝。他想要任何机会，让他的这家造纸公司的纪录片，无论这是什么，这群跟着他的摄像组，
So the there's like a Titanic reference in Booze Cruise, but I don't think it works as visually well as Amazing Race reference for here. Yeah, it totally makes sense to me though. I think Michael is such a fan of pop culture and television and film. Like he wants any opportunity for his documentary of this paper company, whatever this is, this camera crew that follows him around.
他认为自己和当时的娱乐节目处于同一水平。是的，是的。好吧，现在每个人都上了车，我们开始开车到处转。安吉拉，说到开车，我们收到了很多关于我们是如何拍摄这些驾驶镜头的问题。艾米·杰克逊、迪昂德拉·特松、霍莉·E、TJ·麦克米伦、威廉·伯克，还有更多人都问，驾驶场景是怎么拍摄的？你们是真的在开车还是用了绿幕？车内场景用了什么摄像机，
He thinks he's on par with the entertainment of the day. Yes, yes. Well, so now everyone gets in their cars and we kind of start driving around. And Angela, speaking of driving, we had a lot of questions about how we pulled off these driving shots. Amy Jackson, Deondra Tessone, Holly E., TJ McMillan, William Burke, and many more people all asked, how did filming work for the driving scenes? Are you guys actually driving or is there a green screen? What cameras were used in the car scenes
演员们真的在到处开车吗？嗯，首先，演员们确实是在到处开车，那不是绿幕。然后我们去找格雷格，请他谈谈拍摄车内人员是什么感觉。他是这么说的。我在制作中注意到的一件事
and are the actors really driving around? Well, first of all, the actors really are driving around that is not a green screen. And then we went to Greg and we asked him to talk a little bit about what it was like to shoot people in the cars. And here's what he had to say. And one of the things I had noticed in production
就是为我们的剧集拍摄车内场景是多么容易。你基本上只需要把两个角色放进车里，架上微型摄像机，然后到处开，即兴发挥很多。所以《旅行推销员》的想法是，我们可以通过走出办公室获得很多制作价值，而且这对我们来说并不难。
was how easy it was to shoot in a car for our show. You just basically put the two characters in the car and set up lipstick cameras and drove around and improvised a lot. And so the idea for Traveling Salesman was we could get a lot of production value out of getting out of the office and it wouldn't be too hard for us to do.
我们只是改装了这些车，然后他们就出发了。所以这里有个行话提醒，当格雷格谈到“微型摄像机”（lipstick cameras）时。那是那种极小的摄像机，他们会把它们以一定角度装在车里的遮阳板上，一个拍一个乘客，另一个拍另一个乘客。我们就会照格雷格说的做。我们只是到处开车，车里有个小对讲机，
We just tricked out these cars and they would go off. So we have a little lingo alert there when Greg talks about lipstick cameras. Those are itty bitty tiny cameras that they would put up in our visors in the car at an angle, and one would shoot one passenger, and one would shoot the other passenger. And we would just literally do what Greg said. We would just drive around, and we would have a little walkie-talkie in the car,
前面或后面会有一辆车，载着剧组、导演、录音师。他们能听到我们说话。他们可以在一个小移动视频屏幕上看到我们。他们会通过对讲机和我们说话。他们会说，哦，那太棒了。我们要再来一次。然后我们就到处开车。
and there would be a car either in front of us or behind us that had the crew, the director, a sound person. They could hear us. They could see us on a little mobile video screen. And they would talk to us over the walkie talkie. And they would say, oh, that was great. We're going to do that again. And then we would just drive around.
他们会有警车。还记得警车吗，安吉？是的，我们还有摩托车警察，他们会在前面，我们有一条清理出来的路，这样，你知道，我们就不用在不知道我们在拍摄的人群中开车了，对吧？所以很安全。我们基本上就在一个街区绕圈。
They would have police cars. Remember the police cars, Ange? Yeah, we had the motorcycle police guys, too, who would be in the front and we'd have this path that was cleared for us so that, you know, we wouldn't have to drive or around people who didn't know we were filming, right? So it was safe. And we would just basically make a loop usually in one neighborhood.
我们只是反复绕同一个圈。是的，这就是肯特·兹博纳克，也就是“肯特百科”，他必须负责清理。他得给公路巡警或警察打电话，他们会给我们划定一个当天在特定时间内允许使用的区域。我们就绕圈。在洛杉矶找到一个没有棕榈树的圈总是很难。所以我们倾向于在同一个街区反复拍摄，因为显然他们找到了看起来可能像东海岸的树，你知道吗？是的。我们对这些圈非常熟悉。戴夫·罗杰斯在DVD评论音轨里说的一件事是，这是第一次
We just make the same loop over and over. Yeah, that was the whole thing that Kent Zbornak, aka Kentopedia, he would have to clear that. He'd have to call the highway patrol or the police and they would give us a zone that we were allowed to use for a certain period of time on that day. And we would just loop around. And it was always difficult in Los Angeles to find a loop that didn't have any palm trees. So we tend to film in the same neighborhoods over and over because clearly they found trees that looked possibly East Coast-ish, you know? Yes. We got to know these loops very well. One of the things Dave Rogers said in the DVD commentary is that this was the first time that
我们在车里使用了微型摄像机。以前我们拍驾驶场景时，我们的摄像师之一，兰德尔或马特，会蜷缩在后座拿着摄像机。你知道，我看的时候注意到微型摄像机的视频质量有点不同。它不像马特或兰德尔的摄像机那么清晰。看看你，科技达人。你有个科技提醒？
we used the lipstick cameras in the cars. Previously when we had done driving scenes, one of our camera operators, Randall or Matt would be scrunched in the back seat with a camera. And you know, I noticed the video quality was a little different on the lipstick cameras when I was watching it. It's not quite as crisp as a matte camera or a Randall camera. Look at you, Ms. Techie. You got a tech alert there?
看看你。我注意到了。我确实注意到了。所以让我们聊聊所有这些车和他们到处开车的事。嗯，我们看到的第一个场景是安迪和迈克尔，安迪决心利用这段和迈克尔独处的时间来削弱德怀特，对吧？他要破坏他。他问起洗衣的事。迈克尔告诉他德怀特去总公司试图抢他的工作，天哪，安迪得到这个消息真是太高兴了。是的，他要花这一整集的时间
Look at you. I noticed it. I did. So let's talk about all of these cars and all they're driving around. Well, the first scene we really see is Andy and Michael, and Andy is determined to use this one-on-one time with Michael to chip away at Dwight, right? He's gonna undermine him. He asks about the laundry. Michael tells him that Dwight went to corporate to try to get his job and oh my gosh, Andy is like so happy to get this information. Yes, he's gonna spend this whole episode
慢慢削弱德怀特的声誉。是的。嗯，然后我们看到菲利斯，她开进了一家美容院，她和凯伦要去做个超级华丽的改造。我们不知道为什么。看起来就像你以前去商场拍“魅力照”（Glamour Shots）的时候，你做过吗？我从来没拍过魅力照，但我妹妹艾米丽拍过。是的，我也没拍过，但我妹妹蒂娜拍过，他们给她做了个巨大的发型，就像那种蓬松的发型，还有各种化妆。我想还有一条羽毛围巾。
slowly chipping away at Dwight's reputation. Yeah. Well, then we see Phyllis, she pulls into a beauty salon, her and Karen are gonna get some super glam makeovers. We don't know why. It looks like when you used to go to the mall to glamour shots, did you ever do that? I never did glamour shots but my sister Emily did. Yes, I never did it either but my sister Tina Tina did and they gave her this enormous hairdo, like this bouffant hairdo and all this makeup. And I think like a feather boa.
那很常见。那很常见。他们会用绿幕给你拍照，然后如果我没记错的话，会插入不同的背景。比如埃菲尔铁塔。是的。好吧，这就是那个改造看起来的样子。
That was common. That was common. And they would shoot you on a green screen and then sort of insert different backgrounds if I remember correctly. Like the Eiffel Tower. Yeah. Okay. So that is what this makeover looks like.
那可能算是个旧科技提醒。魅力照还存在吗？我不觉得，女士。我不觉得。我觉得在自拍和iPhone时代，已经没有魅力照了。还有滤镜。还有滤镜。魅力照不复存在了。嗯，然后我们还有瑞安和斯坦利。瑞安问斯坦利他能不能在销售拜访中带头。斯坦利说，没有什么比这更让我高兴的了。哦，斯坦利知道些什么，他觉得很有趣。他等不及了。哦，等不及了。我们一会儿就会知道原因。所以现在，当所有这些开车到处转的事情发生时，回到办公室，安吉拉邀请帕姆去喝咖啡。是的，帕姆当时说，什么？
That might be like an old tech alert. Does Glamour Shots still exist? I don't think so lady. I don't think so. I think the era of the selfie and the iPhone, there aren't Glamour Shots. And the filters. And the filters. Glamour Shots are no more. Well, then we also have Ryan and Stanley. more. Well, then we also have Ryan and Stanley. And Ryan asked Stanley if he could take the lead on the sales call. And Stanley is like, nothing would delight me more. Oh, Stanley knows something and he's tickled. He can't wait. Oh, can't wait. We will find out why in a little bit. So now, back at the office while all this driving around is happening, Angela invites Pam to coffee. Yes, and Pam was like, what?
但好吧。现在，私下说一句，我很高兴能拍这场戏。你和我从来没一起拍过戏，更别提一起去外景地了。我们当时很兴奋，杰娜。我们等不及了。所以你在安吉拉·马丁身上看到的那些微笑和快乐，只是因为我能和我的闺蜜拍戏而感到高兴。
But okay. Now, on a personal note, I was thrilled to do this scene. You and I never got to do scenes together, let alone go on a location together. We were giddy, Jenna. We couldn't wait. So some of that smiling and happiness you see in Angela Martin is just me being happy that I get to do a scene with my BFF.
而且我可以表现得正常。我可以微笑，不用尖酸刻薄。安吉拉，我们拿到剧本时太兴奋了。是的。我所有的戏基本上都是和你一起拍的。是的，我们有同样的工作日，然后我们有这个剧本。是的。我所有的戏基本上都是和你一起拍的。是的，我们有同样的工作日，然后我们有几天假。我们当时就像，呜
And I get to be normal. I get to smile and not be snarky. It was so, we were so excited, Angela, when we got this script. Yeah. All of my scenes are basically with you. Yeah, we had the same work day and then we had this script. Yeah. All of my scenes are basically with you. Yeah, we had the same workday and then we had a few days off. It was like we were like, woo
那就像是闺蜜周。是的，对我们来说。嗯，有些人指出在场景结束时，帕姆拿了一个笔记本，人们就问，为什么帕姆带笔记本去喝咖啡？她要记录安吉拉吗？不，不，伙计们，有一句台词被剪掉了。帕姆对安吉拉说，你知道吗？我去转转，记下咖啡订单。看看有没有人想要什么。是的，这在删减片段里。
it was kind of like BFF week. Yeah, for us. Well, some people pointed out that at the end of the scene, Pam grabs a notebook and people were, why is Pam bringing a notebook to coffee? Is she gonna take notes on Angela? No, no, you guys, there was a line that got cut out. Pam says to Angela, you know what? I'll go around and take some coffee orders. I'll see if anybody wants anything. Yes, this is in the deleted scenes.
她转了一圈，梅雷迪思对你非常生气。她说，我为什么要花4美元买一杯牛奶？她非常生气。是的，她和克里德变得非常暴躁，对吧？是的，他们对那些花哨的咖啡订单变得非常暴躁。而且有一个场景，杰娜，真的会让你心碎，因为当我们带着咖啡回来时，很明显托比点咖啡只是为了能和帕姆互动。
She goes around, Meredith gets really angry at you. She's like, why would I pay $4 for milk in a cup? And she gets all angry. Yeah, her and Creed get real cranky, right? Yeah, they get real cranky about the fancy coffee orders. And there is a scene, Jenna, that just will break your heart, because when we come back with the coffee, it's clear that Toby only ordered coffee so he could have some interaction
但当她带着所有咖啡回来分发时，她只是把它递给了凯利，凯利又把它拿给了托比。托比只是透过附件区的玻璃隔断看着帕姆，然后他直接把咖啡扔进了垃圾桶。他甚至没能和她说上话。噢，托比。可怜的托比。托比。太悲伤了。噢，托比。可怜的托比。托比。太悲伤了。嗯，安吉，在剧本里，有一个场景是帕姆在记托比的咖啡订单。哦，是吗？那不在删减片段里。是的，他点了一杯印度拉茶拿铁，帕姆说，天哪，那也是我点的咖啡。他说，哦，真的吗？哦，我们点的咖啡一样。是的。所以他不仅没能喝到帕姆送来的咖啡，他还点了一杯他甚至没怎么
with Pam. But when she comes back with all the coffees and she's passing them around, she just hands it to Kelly, who then takes it to Toby. And Toby just looks at Pam through the glass partition from the annex and he just puts the coffee in the trash. He didn't even get to talk to her. Aw, Toby. Poor Toby. Toby. So sad. to her. Aw, Toby. Poor Toby. Toby. So sad. Well, Ange, in the script, there is a scene where Pam is taking Toby's coffee order. Oh yeah? That's not in the deleted scenes. Yeah, and he orders a chai latte and Pam says, oh my gosh, that's my coffee order. And he's like, oh, really? Oh, we have the same coffee order. Yeah. So not only does he not get his coffee delivered by Pam, he ordered a coffee he didn't even
喝的咖啡，只是为了和她有共同点。托比。哇。哇。他在跟踪帕姆，爱上了她。所以现在伙计们，我们在停车场，德怀特想让自己兴奋起来。他得为这次销售拜访做好准备。
really drink just to have something in common with her. Toby. Wong. Wong. He's stalking Pam and in love with her. So now you guys, we're in the parking lot and Dwight wants to amp himself up. He's got to get pumped for this sales call.
吉姆知道他们进行过无数次销售拜访。他说，你还在做那个？德怀特说，把钥匙给我。然后他放了，我不知道，是莫特利·克鲁乐队还是什么的？再一次，我们看到德怀特像是在摇滚，对着重金属音乐弹空气吉他，像是在打座位来准备。是的。是的，这是他的例行公事，我想。
Jim knows they have been on countless sales calls. He's like, you still do the thing? And Dwight's like, just give me the keys. And then he plays like, I don't know, is it like Montley Crue or something? And once again, we see Dwight like rocking out, doing air guitar at heavy metal, like punching the seat to get ready. Yes. Yeah, this is their this is his routine, I guess.
是的。吉姆知道他们就像老室友。他说，我们走吧。我站在外面。他弹空气吉他。所以他兴奋起来了，因为当他们走进大楼时，德怀特必须表现得像德怀特，他说，你先走，因为他不想从背后被袭击。十分之七的袭击来自后方。对。吉姆说，那另外30%呢？德怀特说，我会挡住的。
Yeah. And Jim knows that they're like old roommates. He's like, Here we go. I stand out here. He does air guitar. So he is amped up because then when they're walking into the building, Dwight has to be Dwight and he's like, you go in first, because he doesn't want to get attacked from behind. Seven out of 10 attacks are from the rear. Right. And Jim is like, well, what about the other 30%? And Dwight's like, I'd block it.
我会挡住的。你伤不了我。然后话还没说完，吉姆就直接出手打了德怀特一下。他震惊了。他不敢相信自己竟然从正面被袭击了。他不敢相信。而且，他快要破功了。雷恩快要笑场了。你完全看得出来。在8分50秒，雷恩快要笑场了。哦，百分之百要笑场了。哦，百分之百，百分之百。嗯，我们有个来自瑞秋·福琼的粉丝提问。吉姆在走进大楼时应该打德怀特吗，因为雷恩看起来真的很震惊？
I'd block it. You can't get me. And then in like mid-sentence, Jim just hauls off and smacks Dwight. And he is shocked. He can't believe he's been attacked from the front. He can't believe it. Also, he's about to break. Rain is about to laugh. You can totally see it. At 8 minutes, 50 seconds, Rain is about to laugh. Oh, 100 percent about to laugh. Oh, a hundred percent, a hundred percent. Well, we had a fan question from Rachel Fortune. Was Jim supposed to slap Dwight as they walk in the building because Rain looked truly shocked?
嗯，伙计们，这是一个剧本里的时刻，但雷恩感到惊讶是有原因的，尽管这是剧本写的。我们问了格雷格。他是这么说的。所以有些人问关于吉姆打德怀特的那一刻。所以，你知道，把他们俩想象成职业生涯早期搭档很有趣。我们给了它一种阿博特和科斯特洛喜剧搭档的感觉，你知道，吉姆突然停下。所以德怀特撞到了头，通常这些小瞬间涉及德怀特受到报应。我记得约翰在我面前走过来，
Well, guys, this was a scripted moment, but there's a reason why Rain was surprised, even though it was scripted. And we asked Greg about it. Here's what he had to say. So some people asked about the the Jim slapping Dwight moment. So, you know, it's fun to think of the two of them as being teamed up earlier in their career. And we we gave it kind of an Abbott and Costello comedy team feel, you know, where Jim is like stopping short. So Dwight hits his head and and usually these little moments involve some comeuppance for Dwight. And I remember John came up to me right
就在我们要拍他打德怀特脸的那部分之前。他说他想真的打雷恩一下，比他们排练的稍微重一点，好让他真的吓一跳。我不记得雷恩是否知情，但只是不想知道是哪一条。但我们商量好了他要拍哪一条。我敢肯定我们用了雷恩真的被约翰打了一下的那一条。所以情况是这样的。在DVD评论音轨里，雷恩和约翰深入讨论了这一刻。雷恩让约翰打他重一点。他说，我想让你打我重一点。关于雷恩，有一点是这样的。他非常讲究方法派，伙计们。当我打他时，
before we were going to shoot the part where he hits Dwight in the face. And he said that he wanted to hit Rain for real a little bit harder than they had worked out just to get a good startle out of him. And I can't recall whether Rain was in on this, but just didn't want to know which take. But we kind of worked out which take he was going to do. And I'm pretty sure we used the one where Rain was really startled that John had hit him. So here's the deal. On the DVD commentary, Rain and John talk in depth about this moment. And Rain asked John to hit him harder. He was like, I want you to hit me hard. And here's the thing about Rain. He's very method you guys. When I slapped him,
还记得“赌场之夜”吗？是的。他对我说，安，你得打我重一点。真的打我。所以在DVD评论音轨里，约翰说，记得吗雷恩，你说过，打我重一点。我说，好吧。当然，他们用了那一条，因为雷恩确实是那种“哇”的反应。然后他差点笑出来。嗯，你完全看得出来他被吓到了。你可以，这最终让一个剧本里的时刻看起来像是即兴的。但它绝对是剧本写的。我记得上面写着类似，
remember in Casino Night? Yeah. He said to me, Ann, you gotta slap me harder. Really slap me. So in the DVD commentary, John was like, remember Rain, you were like, slap me harder. And I was like, okay. And of course, that's the take they use because Rain was legitimately like, whoa. And then he almost started laughing. Well, you can totally tell that he was taken aback. You can, and it ends up making a scripted moment look unscripted. But it was definitely scripted. I remember it said something like,
德怀特被吉姆打了一下头。你知道，每当我们不得不触碰另一位演员时，我们总是会有特技协调员在场，即使是像打耳光这样可能被认为很小的动作。他们实际上教你如何用手掌以某种杯状的方式打人。这样它会发出更大的声音，或者看起来比实际更暴力。所以，你知道，我们一直都有那种训练，所以我猜我应该说雷恩在执行这个动作时没有受伤，但他确实
Dwight gets smacked in the head by Jim. And you know, we would always have stunt coordinators come in anytime we had to put our hands on another actor, even if it was something that might be considered small, like a slap. And they actually teach you how to hit someone with your palm in this certain sort of cupped way. So it makes a louder noise or it looks more violent than it really is. And so, you know, we always had that training in us as well so I guess I should say Rain was not hurt in the execution of this but he was certainly
震惊了。嗯，它奏效了，它让雷恩笑场了，也让其他人笑场了，这就是他们选的那一条。所以女士，我们现在在哪，我们要去进行销售拜访了吗？我们要去了，我们马上就要进入所有这些销售会议，但我们为什么不休息一下，然后一会儿回来接着讲。是的。夏天是蒂姆冰拿铁的季节。这也是徒步季节、泳池季节、野餐季节，
shocked. Well it worked and it cracked Rain up and everyone else and that's the take they picked. So lady where are we are we going into some sales calls? We are we're about to go into all these sales meetings, but why don't we take a break and then we'll pick up right there in just a moment. Yeah. Summer is Tim's ice latte season. It's also hike season, pool season, picnic season,
是的，我是说“我准备好了”的季节。所以喝杯蒂姆冰拿铁吧，现在搅打过，口感更顺滑。在蒂姆APP上订购你的，
and yeah, I'm down season. So drink it up with Tim's ice lattes, now whipped for a smooth taste. Order yours on the Tim's Ice Latte's, now whipped for a smooth taste. Order yours on the Tim's app today at participating restaurants in Canada for a limited time. All right, we are back. Let's talk about all of these sales meetings. Yes, I think the first one is Michael and Andy.
在加拿大参与活动的餐厅限时供应。好了，我们回来了。让我们聊聊所有这些销售会议。是的，我想第一个是迈克尔和安迪。
And Jenna, once again, we see that Michael is a good salesman. He knows how to connect with people. He really does. He really does. He doesn't know how to be someone's boss. That is his failing. He thinks that he's supposed to entertain you as a boss.
杰娜，我们再次看到迈克尔是个好推销员。他知道如何与人建立联系。他确实知道。他确实知道。他不知道如何做别人的老板。那是他的失败之处。他认为作为老板他应该娱乐大家。
But he does know how to connect with people one on one. And he really connects with this guy over fishing. He complements the fish that he caught. And it's a callback to Lake Wallenpah pack. Love a callback. Love a callback. And then Andy's like, yeah, my dad has a Bayliner, whatever he says, I shot a shark.
但他确实知道如何与人一对一地建立联系。他真的通过钓鱼和这个人建立了联系。他称赞了他钓到的鱼。这是对沃伦帕克湖的呼应。喜欢呼应。喜欢呼应。然后安迪说，是的，我爸爸有一艘贝莱纳游艇，无论他说什么，我射杀了一条鲨鱼。
I mean, if you were a true fisherman, the idea of shooting a fish in any way is so off-putting. There's sort of an art to fishing and a lot of people even do like the throwback, you know, if they're fishing on a lake. So you could just tell this really was off-putting to this man. Angela, do you know all of that
我的意思是，如果你是一个真正的渔夫，以任何方式射杀一条鱼的想法都是非常令人反感的。钓鱼有一种艺术，很多人甚至会做那种“放生”，你知道，如果他们在湖上钓鱼的话。所以你可以看出这真的让这个人感到反感。安吉拉，你知道所有这些
because of your ex-boyfriend that made you watch Bassmasters? Oh god, you had to bring up. I want to tell you Angela, after we talked about Bassmasters on the podcast, they sent us each a little goody bag of stuff and one of the things that they sent us, it was so sweet. They just said hey, thanks for talking about us It was totally organic and random, but they sent me this Journal a leather bound journal. It's so nice a leather bound journal It says Bass Masters on it and I love it is my new favorite journal So now because of your ex- ex boyfriend making you watch Bass Masters
是因为你的前男友让你看《低音大师》（Bassmasters）吗？哦天哪，你非要提这个。我想告诉你安吉拉，在我们播客上聊过《低音大师》之后，他们给我们每人寄了一个小礼包，其中一件他们寄的东西，太贴心了。他们只是说嘿，谢谢你们谈论我们。这完全是自然而随机的，但他们寄给我这本日志，一本皮质日志。太好了，一本皮质日志。上面写着《低音大师》，我喜欢它，这是我最喜欢的新日志。所以现在因为你的前前男友让你看《低音大师》，
and you bringing it up on this podcast, I now journal in a Bass Masters journal. That is what has happened. Well, you're welcome. And Kyle says you're welcome. That was his name. Well, thank you, Kyle. Oh, no, it's out there. Oh, boy. Yeah. Well, Bass Masters sent me a hoodie that no. It's out there. Oh, boy. Yeah.
而你在播客上提到了它，我现在在《低音大师》的日志里写日记。这就是发生的事情。嗯，不客气。凯尔说不客气。那是他的名字。嗯，谢谢你，凯尔。哦，不，这下传出去了。哦，天哪。是的。嗯，《低音大师》寄给我一件连帽衫，不。这下传出去了。哦，天哪。是的。
Well, Bassmaster sent me a hoodie that I love. And I walk around with my Bassmaster's hoodie. Yeah. So here's the thing. There's a great little moment in the DVD commentary about this scene where Ed says that he and Steve did go off script in this scene. And the actor that plays the man, the business owner
嗯，《低音大师》寄给我一件我喜欢的连帽衫。我穿着我的《低音大师》连帽衫到处走。是的。所以情况是这样的。DVD评论音轨里关于这场戏有一个很棒的小瞬间，艾德说他和史蒂夫在这场戏里确实脱离了剧本。而扮演那个男人的演员，那个企业主，
they're talking to, was not really ready for them to go off script. He wasn't. Oh, dear. And he just gave them this sort of odd, quizzical look. Like, what are you talking about? And Dave Rogers is in this commentary, and he goes, but it was perfect.
他们正在交谈的对象，并没有真正准备好让他们脱离剧本。他没有。哦，天哪。他只是给了他们那种奇怪的、困惑的表情。就像，你们在说什么？戴夫·罗杰斯在评论音轨里，他说，但这太完美了。
So that look you see this man giving Michael and Andy like what is really earnest. Oh my gosh. I love that. I love that tidbit. Well guys, the actor who plays the client that Michael and Andy are talking to is named Warren Sweeney. So Warren, while you were surprised, your look worked. It totally worked. Well, then we cut to the car and you can tell Michael is not pleased with Andy, but Andy turns it around and he's like,
所以你看到这个男人给迈克尔和安迪的那种表情，就像“什么”一样，是非常真诚的。天哪。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个花絮。嗯，伙计们，扮演迈克尔和安迪正在交谈的客户的演员叫沃伦·斯威尼。所以沃伦，虽然你很惊讶，但你的表情奏效了。它完全奏效了。嗯，然后我们切到车里，你可以看出迈克尔对安迪不满意，但安迪扭转了局面，他说，
I'm so sorry for screwing up our sales call. I really shrewded it. Yeah. That's what we say around the office. When someone really screws sales call. I really shrewded it. Yeah. That's what we say around the office when someone really screws up, we say they shrewded it. And then he's like, I wonder how that name came up. I wonder if it's because of Dwight. And Michael gives him nothing.
我很抱歉搞砸了我们的销售拜访。我真的把它“搞砸”（shrewded）了。是的。这就是我们在办公室里说的。当有人真的搞砸了销售拜访。我真的把它“搞砸”了。是的。这就是我们在办公室里说的，当有人真的搞砸了，我们说他们把它“搞砸”了。然后他说，我想知道那个名字是怎么来的。我想知道是不是因为德怀特。迈克尔什么也没给他。
Michael's like, well, who knows how words are formed. Like he's not getting it. And Andy's getting so frustrated. Andy is planting all these seeds that Dwight is an idiot and Michael is not getting it. It's awesome. So let's now talk about Phyllis and Karen's meeting. They get a very large order from this gentleman. Oh, this is my St. Louis catch. All right. This is around. Okay. This is around 11 minutes, 33 seconds. And Phyllis goes, well, thanks.
迈克尔说，嗯，谁知道词是怎么形成的。就像他没听懂。而安迪变得非常沮丧。安迪在种下所有这些种子，说德怀特是个白痴，而迈克尔没听懂。太棒了。所以现在让我们聊聊菲利斯和凯伦的会议。他们从这位绅士那里得到了一个非常大的订单。哦，这是我的圣路易斯收获。好的。这是在。好的。这是在11分33秒左右。菲利斯说，嗯，谢谢。
That's a big order. She doesn't say order. That's a big order. It says like order. Yeah, that's right in line with FARC. Oh, St. Louis catch. And then and then she asked how his wife is doing. And he shows a photo of himself and his wife on vacation.
那是个大订单。她没说订单。那是个大订单。它说的是像订单一样。是的，这和FARC（注：此处指代不明，可能是口误或特定梗）一致。哦，圣路易斯收获。然后她问他妻子怎么样。他展示了一张他和妻子度假的照片。
And they look just like her, the same hair, the same makeup and Karen's like, ah, I see what you were doing, Phyllis, very smart. Okay, we've got to talk about Dwight and Jim in their sales call, cause Jenna, they clearly have a whole shtick. Yes. I loved it.
他们看起来就像她，同样的头发，同样的妆容，凯伦说，啊，我明白你在做什么了，菲利斯，非常聪明。好的，我们得聊聊德怀特和吉姆的销售拜访，因为杰娜，他们显然有一整套把戏。是的。我喜欢它。
It's soick. Yes. I loved it. It's so seamless. Yes. I want you to know, my kids laugh so hard when Dwight, when he's making the call and he's going seven, three. They were cracking up. Well, I don't know about you, Angela, but I hate those robo call customer service lines so much that I just like immediately when they come up, I'm like agent speak to a speak to pharmacist agent.
太无缝了。是的。我想让你知道，我的孩子们在德怀特打电话时笑得很大声，当他说七、三的时候。他们笑得前仰后合。嗯，我不知道你怎么样，安吉拉，但我非常讨厌那些机器人客服电话，以至于当它们出现时，我立刻就会说，代理，和代理说话，和药剂师说话，代理。
I won't even say any numbers. I'm like I can't I can't. Jenna, I have such a fond memory of my dad. It's weird, you know, when you when someone you love so much passes away. And I don't mean to be a Debbie Downer here in this moment, because this is a happy memory for me. But it's interesting the things your brain latches on to and holds dear things you would never ever expect. But I have such a vivid memory of my dad on the phone with clearly
我甚至不会说任何数字。我说我不能，我不能。杰娜，我对我的父亲有一个非常美好的回忆。这很奇怪，你知道，当你深爱的人去世时。我不是想在这里表现得扫兴，因为这对我是个快乐的回忆。但有趣的是，你的大脑会抓住并珍视那些你永远不会预料到的事情。但我对我父亲在电话里和显然
like some kind of like robot. And he's he's this you know, he was just this sweet cowboy, you know, southern guy and he was going five. No. Yes. Talk to person, person. Isn't like whatever the password was. Tractor, tractor. Oh, I love that, Ange. I love that you shared that. It made me think of him. It's weird. It's weird the way your brain works like that. Your brain and your heart. Okay, so yes, so Dwight is doing this call. We don't know who he's calling and Jim presses on with his sales pitch, right?
某种机器人通话有非常生动的记忆。他是个，你知道，他只是个可爱的牛仔，你知道，南方人，他当时在说五。不。是的。和人说话，人。不是像密码是什么。拖拉机，拖拉机。哦，我喜欢那个，安吉。我喜欢你分享这个。它让我想起了他。这很奇怪。这很奇怪，你的大脑就是这样运作的。你的大脑和你的心。好的，所以是的，德怀特在打这个电话。我们不知道他在给谁打电话，吉姆继续他的销售推销，对吧？
Yeah, through all of this. And the guy is like, listen, I don't know what to tell you. I mean, I just maybe feel more comfortable with the with a bigger company with one of the big guys. And they're like, well, is customer service important to you? And he's like, it's very important. And he's like, well, we've been on hold with the customer service department of a big company. Oh, and there's the switch. Aha. There was a whole purpose. And then he calls Dunder Mifflin customer service and Kelly answers. I was like,
是的，贯穿这一切。那个人说，听着，我不知道该告诉你什么。我的意思是，我可能觉得和大公司，和大人物之一合作更舒服。他们说，嗯，客户服务对你重要吗？他说，非常重要。他们说，嗯，我们一直在大公司的客户服务部门等待。哦，这就是转折。啊哈。原来是有目的的。然后他给邓德·米夫林客户服务部打电话，凯利接了。我当时想，
Hey, oh my god, what are you guys doing? Yes. Yes. So amazing. And then the guy is like sold. So you my business sold and Dwight handsome his business card and Jenna I love what's on Dwight's business card. His cell number, his pager number, his home number, and his other pager number. Yeah, and then he says, I take no days off, I've never been sick,
嘿，天哪，你们在做什么？是的。是的。太神奇了。然后那个人说，成交。所以你，我的生意成交了，德怀特递给他名片，杰娜，我喜欢德怀特名片上的内容。他的手机号、传呼机号、家庭电话号，还有他的另一个传呼机号。是的，然后他说，我不休假，我从没生过病，
and I don't celebrate any major holidays. And he's like, okay, okay, I got it. Interesting tech alert, his email was not on his business card, Jenna. Huh. Nowadays, I think your email would be on there. For sure. For sure.
而且我不庆祝任何重大节日。他说，好的，好的，我明白了。有趣的科技提醒，他的电子邮件没在名片上，杰娜。嗯。现在，我觉得你的电子邮件会写在上面。肯定的。肯定的。
But we shot this in the Stone Age. So now Ryan and Stanley go into the church for their sales call and these four older, very sort of like dignified black men in their suits walk out to him. They're clearly an older generation. They're Stanley's generation. And there's this young white kid who Jenna, I don't think, generation. They're Stanley's generation. And there's this young white kid who Jenna, I don't think, I don't think Ryan's been in a church in a while.
但我们在石器时代拍的这个。所以现在瑞安和斯坦利走进教堂进行销售拜访，这四个年长的、非常庄重的黑人穿着西装走出来。他们显然是老一辈。他们是斯坦利那一代的。这里有个年轻的白人孩子，杰娜，我不认为，他们是斯坦利那一代的。这里有个年轻的白人孩子，杰娜，我不认为，我不认为瑞安有一阵子没进过教堂了。
No, and we've established that the way all these sales calls are successful is by people connecting with their client in some personal way. And we quickly see that Ryan is going to have a hard time connecting with these gentlemen. And he just sort of starts stammering and he just keeps introducing himself over and over again. Hi, hi, hi. Hi. Hi. I love that Stanley's like, I'm not helping you. In fact, I'm just going to ignore you.
不，我们已经确定了，所有这些销售拜访之所以成功，是因为人们以某种个人方式与客户建立了联系。我们很快看到瑞安很难与这些绅士建立联系。他只是开始结结巴巴，他只是不停地自我介绍。嗨，嗨，嗨。嗨。嗨。我喜欢斯坦利说，我不会帮你的。事实上，我只是要无视你。
I'm going to turn away and do my crossword and let you just, what's the expression to know? Or just you flap in the wind. In the wind. Yeah. Something like that. He's just going to hang him out to dry there. It's so good I was able to find out the names of two of the clients But I couldn't find names for the other guys But Landon H Lewis jr. And Leon Simmons jr. Are two of the clients in that scene I also loved how all of the men in the scene were so much taller than BJ
我要转过身去做我的填字游戏，让你，怎么说来着？或者让你在风中飘摇。在风中。是的。类似那样。他只是要让他晾在那里。太好了，我能够找到其中两个客户的名字，但我没能找到其他人的名字。但兰登·H·刘易斯二世和莱昂·西蒙斯二世是那场戏里的两个客户。我也喜欢这场戏里所有的男人都比BJ高那么多。
how all of the men in the scene were so much taller than BJ. Because it really also made him just look so young, you know? Yeah. Next to them, just the size difference. Yes. And then later when they're in the car, Angela, Stanley cannot stop laughing. There are all these shots that go back to them
场景里的男人们都比BJ高出那么多。因为这确实让他看起来非常年轻，你知道吗？是的。站在他们旁边，体型差异太明显了。没错。后来他们在车里的时候，安吉拉，斯坦利笑得停不下来。镜头一直在他们之间切换，
driving back to Dunder Mifflin, and Stanley is just like, can't believe he's so delighted by how that went. He's so tickled. It clearly made his day. I don't know that Stanley gets much joy out of working at Dunder Mifflin, but this was a real highlight for him. And there's this moment that Leslie talks about in the DVD. He said in the script, it was just that Stanley is driving and laughing, and they just kind of let him go. And he improvised the whole thing about, hi, hi, you sounded like my six-month-old niece.
开车回邓德·米福林，斯坦利简直不敢相信，他对事情的进展感到非常高兴。他被逗乐了。这显然让他这一天过得很开心。我不知道斯坦利在邓德·米福林工作能得到多少快乐，但这对他来说确实是一个亮点。DVD里莱斯利提到了这一刻。他说剧本里只是写斯坦利在开车时大笑，他们就让他自由发挥了。他即兴表演了整段关于“嗨，嗨，你听起来像我六个月大的侄女”的内容。
And like all of that, Leslie was just riffing. Oh, that was so good. I know. And he said, in fact, whenever Stanley would go off on Ryan, as he has throughout the show, they would just let Leslie just go. And I think there's some amazing moments. Oh, yes.
所有这些都是莱斯利即兴发挥的。哦，那太棒了。我知道。他说，事实上，每当斯坦利像在剧中那样对瑞安发火时，他们都会让莱斯利自由发挥。我觉得有一些非常精彩的时刻。哦，是的。
Yes. Well, you know, and this is Ryan's second sales call now that has not gone well. Remember, he went on the initiation sales call with Dwight. They did not make the sale. And now he's gone out on this call with Stanley. Now I believe Stanley's gonna save this sale. Oh, Stanley for sure saved it. Okay, so while all of these sales meetings are happening,
是的。嗯，你知道，这是瑞安第二次销售拜访，结果都不太好。还记得他和德怀特一起去的那次入职销售拜访吗？他们没谈成。现在他又和斯坦利一起去了。现在我相信斯坦利会挽救这次销售。哦，斯坦利肯定挽救了它。好吧，就在这些销售会议进行的同时，
Pam and Angela are at the coffee shop. Angela is in such a great mood and she's telling Pam a story about how she had this friend who was in need and this gallant man came to her rescue. Yeah she's like he must really care for her a lot because he did this wonderful thing for my friend. Yeah she's talking in code. She's speaking in code. She's like my friend friend, let's call her Noel. And this gallant gentleman, we'll call him Kurt. Well, we all know that Kurt is Dwight's middle name, right?
帕姆和安吉拉在咖啡店。安吉拉心情非常好，她正在给帕姆讲一个故事，说她有个朋友遇到了困难，然后一位勇敢的男士挺身而出救了她。是的，她说他一定非常关心她，因为他为我的朋友做了这件美妙的事。是的，她在用暗语说话。她在用暗语。她说“我的朋友，朋友”，我们叫她诺埃尔吧。而这位勇敢的绅士，我们叫他库尔特。嗯，我们都知道库尔特是德怀特的中间名，对吧？
Yes. And we got a lot of fan questions about this, Angela. Kenzie B., Elizabeth R., Julia Lee, Nicole Fink, and Katie Krull all want to know when Angela refers to her friend Noel, is that because Noel is Angela's middle name? It definitely sounds like a very Angela Martin middle name. Well, yes, it is Angela's middle name. Angela thinks she's being really savvy, but Pam totally knows who she's talking about. But yes, that is her middle name. But Jenna, I have a question for you. Okay.
是的。我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝提问，安吉拉。肯齐·B、伊丽莎白·R、朱莉娅·李、妮可·芬克和凯蒂·克鲁尔都想知道，当安吉拉提到她的朋友诺埃尔时，是因为诺埃尔是安吉拉的中间名吗？这听起来确实非常像安吉拉·马丁的中间名。嗯，是的，这就是安吉拉的中间名。安吉拉以为自己很聪明，但帕姆完全知道她在说谁。但没错，那就是她的中间名。但是珍娜，我有个问题要问你。好的。
Is Noel in the script? Because I have a little story about that middle name and I'm curious. I think what was in the script, Angela actually says this. She says, well, a friend of mine, let's just call her, oh, let's just call her me. What? And then you giggle. Okay, so my memory of this is when we were shooting it that day, that the writers were pitching me different middle names like different things to say I know in one of them it
剧本里有“诺埃尔”这个名字吗？因为关于那个中间名我有个小故事，我很好奇。我想剧本里写的是，安吉拉实际上是这么说的。她说：“嗯，我有个朋友，我们叫她……哦，我们叫她‘我’吧。”什么？然后你咯咯笑了。好吧，我的记忆是，那天我们拍摄的时候，编剧们在向我提议不同的中间名，比如不同的说法。我知道其中一个，
was Colette I have such a memory of saying that and and then we said Noel and I like Noel the best because it sounds very sort of Angela Martin doesn't it's her love of Christmas her love of the story of Christmas, that Noelle would be her middle name. And that's the one we went with. And Dave Rogers talks about it in the DVD commentary. And he goes, I remember it being Collette. And he thought maybe I improvised Noelle.
是科莱特。我记得我说过那个名字，然后我们说了诺埃尔，我最喜欢诺埃尔，因为它听起来很像安吉拉·马丁，不是吗？她对圣诞节的热爱，她对圣诞故事的热爱，所以诺埃尔作为她的中间名很合适。这就是我们最终采用的名字。戴夫·罗杰斯在DVD评论中也提到了这一点。他说，我记得当时是科莱特。他以为可能是我即兴发挥用了诺埃尔。
But I didn't. That was a writer's pitch. I mean, I think I was part of the dialogue. I think we were pitching names. But that all sort of happened in the moment. I love it. It's perfect. Angela Noelle Martin, and I believe that will appear on your wedding invitation. Oh, yeah. It's now it's now part of my character's show Bible. We had another fan catch in this scene, Angela. Sarah Rouse wrote in to say, "'Pam is holding a piece of paper at the coffee shop.
但我没有。那是编剧提议的。我的意思是，我想我是对话的一部分。我想我们当时在提议名字。但这一切都是在那一刻发生的。我喜欢它。太完美了。安吉拉·诺埃尔·马丁，我相信这会出现在你的结婚请柬上。哦，是的。它现在已经成为我角色剧集设定的一部分了。安吉拉，我们在这一幕中还有另一个粉丝发现。莎拉·劳斯写信说：“帕姆在咖啡店拿着一张纸。
What is that supposed to be and what does it say?' Well, Sarah, that was the list of coffee orders from those deleted scenes. I had all the coffee orders written down on that piece of paper and I was gonna use it to make my order. Well, Angela, also in this scene, just because we were talking about it earlier,
那是什么？上面写了什么？”嗯，莎拉，那是那些被删减片段里的咖啡订单列表。我把所有的咖啡订单都写在那张纸上了，我打算用它来点单。嗯，安吉拉，同样在这一幕里，因为我们之前谈到过，
your flower hairdo is on full display. Just, if you really want some great shots of it, guys, here it is, her WTF hairdo right here. WTF, well, wait, wait, I have something to share. So while we were on a break, I had been texting Kim Ferry about this hair and she texted back. And so this is what she had to say about it. I said, Oh my gosh, it's a real time tidbit. It's a real time tidbit.
你的花朵发型完全展示出来了。伙计们，如果你们真的想看它的精彩镜头，就在这儿，她那WTF发型就在这儿。WTF，等等，等等，我有东西要分享。所以当我们休息的时候，我一直在给金·费里发短信讨论这个发型，她回信了。这就是她对此的评价。我说，天哪，这是一个实时花絮。这是一个实时花絮。
It just came in a few minutes ago. I said, Kim, what was the inspiration for this bun? I mean, I know that we thought my character was gonna like be in a great mood. And so we wanted to try something new. She said, yes, here is the inspiration. She said, my first job in the business was working on a sci-fi show called Babylon 5.
几分钟前刚发过来的。我说，金，这个发髻的灵感是什么？我的意思是，我知道我们当时认为我的角色心情会很好。所以我们想尝试一些新的东西。她说，是的，灵感就在这里。她说，我在这个行业的第一份工作是在一部叫《巴比伦5号》的科幻剧组。
I worked on this show for five years and I couldn't use any contemporary hairstyles because they wanted the hairstyles to look futuristic. So I started coming up with all these different kind of braids and and buns with wires and fancy updo's and Zulu knots. Basically anything different that I could think of and your bun with those fun swirls was a good one for me because I had done it on Babylon 5. It's fast and easy, but technically this is a sci-fi hairstyle. Oh. My. Gosh.
我在那个剧组工作了五年，我不能使用任何现代发型，因为他们希望发型看起来有未来感。所以我开始想出各种各样的辫子和带有电线、花哨盘发和祖鲁结的发髻。基本上我能想到的任何不同的东西，而你那个带有有趣漩涡的发髻对我来说很合适，因为我在《巴比伦5号》里做过。它既快又简单，但从技术上讲，这是一种科幻发型。天。哪。
Isn't that great? Don't you feel like Dwight would have loved it because he was Mr. Sci-Fi? Yes! Yes! No wonder she did her hair in this Babylon 5 hairstyle to thank Dwight for his like, favor. Yeah! So yes, this hairstyle inspired by Babylon 5. It's the Sci-Fi bun. I don't think I could love that more. Kim Ferry, thank you for the real-time tidbit. Thank you, Kim Ferry. Sam just wrote, Beats, Bears, Babylon 5. Beats? Oh wait, here we go. Bears, Beats, Babylon 5, buns. Oh, okay. So now everybody is coming back from their sales calls. Everyone's done. And
那不是很棒吗？你不觉得德怀特会喜欢它吗，因为他是科幻迷？是的！是的！难怪她做了这个《巴比伦5号》发型来感谢德怀特的“恩惠”。是的！所以没错，这个发型灵感来自《巴比伦5号》。这是科幻发髻。我想我不能更喜欢它了。金·费里，谢谢你的实时花絮。谢谢你，金·费里。萨姆刚写道：节拍、熊、巴比伦5号。节拍？哦等等，开始了。熊、节拍、巴比伦5号、发髻。哦，好吧。现在每个人都从销售拜访回来了。大家都结束了，然后
we have this amazing scene in the car with Karen and Phyllis. Phyllis is so good in this scene because you guys, she is going to reveal such a big plot point and she just throws it away, right? It's not like belabored in any way. It's so perfect. Yeah. She's like, Karen, I had a lot of fun with you today. I really enjoy spending time with you. They're bonding, they feel good.
我们在车里有这一幕精彩的戏，凯伦和菲利斯。菲利斯在这一幕里表现得太好了，因为伙计们，她要揭露一个如此重大的情节转折，而她只是随口一说，对吧？一点也不刻意。太完美了。是的。她说：“凯伦，我今天和你玩得很开心。我真的很喜欢和你在一起。”她们在建立感情，感觉很好。
And then she just very offhandedly says, and I'm really glad you're with Jim. That makes me really happy because, you know, he was really hung up on Pam for such a long time. And she's not even looking at Karen. She's looking in a rear view mirror. She's turning. She's just driving.
然后她非常漫不经心地说：“我真的很高兴你和吉姆在一起。这让我很高兴，因为，你知道，他很长一段时间都对帕姆念念不忘。”她甚至没有看凯伦。她在看后视镜。她在转弯。她只是在开车。
She's just sort of saying something off the cuff. And it's that much more powerful. And then Rashida, oh my gosh, her reaction is so perfect. It's a fantastic scene, fantastic scene. I feel like her pulse stops for a second. Like I feel like I can see the wind go out of her. Right? Yeah, yeah, I do too.
她只是随口说了些什么。这让它更有冲击力。然后拉什达，天哪，她的反应太完美了。这是一场精彩的戏，精彩的戏。我觉得她的脉搏停了一秒。就像我感觉我能看到她泄了气一样。对吧？是的，是的，我也这么觉得。
You just, you see it hit her like a freight train, but she can't react. Yeah. The way it's really hitting her. It's so well done. These ladies did such a great job. I agree. Yes. Well, Andy is the first person
你只是，你看到它像货运列车一样撞向她，但她无法做出反应。是的。它真正击中她的方式。做得太好了。这些女士们做得太棒了。我同意。是的。嗯，安迪是第一个
to actually get back to the office. And he starts, he starts sneaking around Dwight's desk. He goes through his car. Yeah, Andy is a total snake. I mean, what the heck? I know. And he finds this toll booth receipt that proves that Dwight was in New York this morning.
真正回到办公室的人。他开始在德怀特的办公桌周围鬼鬼祟祟。他翻了他的车。是的，安迪是个彻头彻尾的阴险小人。我的意思是，搞什么鬼？我知道。他发现了这张收费站收据，证明德怀特今天早上在纽约。
He didn't oversleep like he claimed. And he marches into Michael's office and he's like, I found this toll booth receipt. I wonder what he was doing. Maybe he was talking to Jan. And then he says like, I found this toll booth receipt. I wonder what he was doing. Was he, maybe he was talking to Jan. And then he says like, I seem to kind of remember, I don't know who told me this, even though, Jenna, this was like, like an hour ago. He's like, I don't know who told me this.
他并没有像他声称的那样睡过头。他大步走进迈克尔的办公室说：“我发现了这张收费站收据。我想知道他在干什么。也许他在和简说话。”然后他说：“我发现了这张收费站收据。我想知道他在干什么。他在……也许他在和简说话。”然后他说：“我好像记得，我不知道是谁告诉我的，尽管，珍娜，这就像是一个小时前的事。”他说：“我不知道是谁告诉我的。”
It was something. And then he has maybe one of my favorite quotes of this episode. He was like, there's a story, I don't know. It was about laundry and betrayal. In my mind, this is now a lifetime movie called Laundry and Betrayal. I want to see it. Yes. Yes. Laundry and Betrayal. I want to see this film. I do too.
那是某件事。然后他说了这集里我最喜欢的台词之一。他说：“有个故事，我不知道。是关于洗衣和背叛的。”在我脑海里，这现在是一部叫《洗衣与背叛》的电视电影。我想看。是的。是的。《洗衣与背叛》。我想看这部电影。我也想。
Well, so Michael calls Jan and Jan is like, well, I didn't speak to Dwight, but he did not give a reason for why he was here. Yes, this is my kid's favorite part. My kid's favorite part is Jan goes, he did sign into the security sign in sheet, but under state your business, he wrote beeswax, not yours incorporated. I loved that too. My kids loved that. Well when Dwight gets back to the office Michael confronts him. He's like where were you? Tell me where you were and Dwight will not say he won't say where he was. He overslept the damn rooster den crow. Yeah, but he will not, he will not fess up and this becomes a problem. And Pam knows why. Pam and Angela are exchanging looks. Angela is sweating it. She's horrified
嗯，所以迈克尔给简打了电话，简说：“嗯，我没和德怀特说话，但他没说他为什么来这里。”是的，这是我孩子最喜欢的部分。我孩子最喜欢的部分是简说：“他确实在安全签到表上签了名，但在‘说明你的事由’一栏，他写了‘蜂蜡，不关你的事有限公司’。”我也喜欢那个。我的孩子们很喜欢。嗯，当德怀特回到办公室时，迈克尔质问他。他说：“你去哪儿了？告诉我你去哪儿了。”德怀特就是不说，他不会说他去哪儿了。他睡过头了，该死的公鸡没打鸣。是的，但他就是不肯坦白，这成了个问题。帕姆知道原因。帕姆和安吉拉交换了眼神。安吉拉在冒汗。她很惊恐，
that Dwight's going through this, but she doesn't want people to know about them. It's very layered emotionally for Angela. Well, it leads to a break room scene with Dwight and Angela, where you are again not facing one another. One of your famous, famous break room scenes. There's a little bit of heartbreak in the break room in this scene. Oh, lady, I noticed it too. Here's what we had.
德怀特正在经历这一切，但她不想让人们知道他们的事。这对安吉拉来说在情感上非常有层次。嗯，这导致了休息室里德怀特和安吉拉的一幕，你们再次没有面对面。你们著名的休息室场景之一。这一幕的休息室里有一点心碎。哦，女士，我也注意到了。这是我们有的。
My mama knitted me a sexy sweater. I thought my life would get so much better. what we had. That was by Michelle Ferguson. Michelle, you know how much we love that song. We love it! Yeah! Michelle, I literally listen to it all the time. It's super catchy.
“我妈妈给我织了一件性感的毛衣，我以为我的生活会变得更好。”我们有的。那是米歇尔·弗格森唱的。米歇尔，你知道我们有多喜欢那首歌。我们喜欢它！是的！米歇尔，我真的经常听它。它超级洗脑。
It's really catchy. I really love it. Someone give this woman a music contract. We'll buy it. OK. We love it. Yeah. So Dwight is like, listen, why don't we just come clean
它真的很洗脑。有人给这位女士一份音乐合同吧。我们会买的。好的。我们喜欢它。是的。所以德怀特说：“听着，为什么我们不坦白，
and let people know our love for one another? So this scene actually went on. It's not in the deleted scenes, but we did shoot a little bit longer of a version where as I cry behind me, Dwight's like, don't cry monkey, monkeys don't cry. Aw, I kind of wish that was still in there. I know, I know. Well, Angela, a few people wrote in about this scene
让大家知道我们彼此的爱呢？”所以这一幕其实还在继续。它不在删减片段里，但我们确实拍了一个稍微长一点的版本，当我在背后哭泣时，德怀特说：“别哭，小猴子，猴子不哭。”啊，我真希望那段还在里面。我知道，我知道。嗯，安吉拉，几个人写信问关于这一幕的事，
because they noted that when you start dating Andy, you have no problem with everyone in the office knowing it. Oh, well, Angela revenge dates Andy, you guys. Andy is not her true love that she wants to protect and keep all to herself because it's so special. She's starting to date Andy because she's mad as hell at Dwight. Right. Very differentight. Right. Very different motivation. Right.
因为他们注意到当你开始和安迪约会时，你对办公室里每个人都知道这件事一点意见都没有。哦，嗯，安吉拉在用安迪进行报复性约会，伙计们。安迪不是她想要保护并独自占有的真爱，因为那太特别了。她开始和安迪约会是因为她对德怀特气疯了。对。非常不同的动机。对。
In the meantime, Karen and Jim have gone to coffee. And Karen is going to ask Jim if he had feelings for Pam. And lady, I have a clip. Sam, play the clip because everything you need to know is right here, Karen. Why couldn't you hear it? So many questions. Do you have a thing for Pam? Pam? Did I ever have a thing for her?
与此同时，凯伦和吉姆去喝咖啡了。凯伦要问吉姆是否对帕姆有感觉。女士，我有一个片段。萨姆，播放那个片段，因为你需要知道的一切都在这里，凯伦。“为什么你听不到？这么多问题。你对帕姆有意思吗？帕姆？我曾经对她有意思吗？
No. Why? Did she do something? It's so clear. That's all you need to know, Karen. He clearly has a thing for her. But, ah, poor Karen. She, you know, he convinces her that he doesn't. Maybe he's not ready to admit it, right? And she is not ready to really see truth. But you know down deep she knows.
没有。为什么？她做了什么吗？”太明显了。这就是你需要知道的一切，凯伦。他显然对她有意思。但是，啊，可怜的凯伦。她，你知道，他让她相信他没有。也许他还没准备好承认，对吧？而她还没准备好真正面对真相。但你知道在内心深处她知道。
Well, Lady, she says, I moved here. Yeah, I moved here. And I think that's the part of Karen that doesn't want to see the truth, because it's a little humiliating to deal with the fact that you moved somewhere for the wrong person. Exactly. We all have a friend who has moved somewhere for someone and then it didn't work out. It's devastating. But then they hang on to it because they moved. Yeah. And it's like you want it, you're willing it to be right even though you know it's wrong. So this is the moment where I know we've been coming down kind of hard on wishy washy Jim, but this is the moment where Karen is now not reading the signals. No, no. So Ange, should we go back to Dunder Mifflin to this grand announcement from Dwight?
嗯，女士，她说：“我搬到这里来了。”是的，我搬到这里来了。我认为那是凯伦不想面对真相的部分，因为处理你为了错误的人搬到某个地方的事实有点丢脸。没错。我们都有一个朋友为了某人搬到某个地方，结果却没成。这太令人崩溃了。但他们坚持下去，因为他们搬了。是的。就像你想要它，你强迫它是对的，即使你知道它是错的。所以这就是我知道我们一直对优柔寡断的吉姆有点严厉的时刻，但这是凯伦现在没有读懂信号的时刻。不，不。所以安吉，我们要回到邓德·米福林，去听德怀特的那个重大声明吗？
Yes! I mean, he makes this huge, like, speech and basically he's like, I'm quitting, so I quit. Yeah, he quits. Rather than reveal his secret about his relationship with Angela and where he was this morning, he quits. Dwight leaves. He gives Michael his box of things. He does keep his Dwight bobblehead. I'll let you know. Of course. There is a deleted scene where he goes around and gives us all items from the box. Jenna, it's very funny. I remember shooting that. Yeah. And then he walks out and he does his salute. It's the same salute from the initiation. Nice little call back there. And Dwight is gone. Yeah. And Angela, he has a line that, oh my gosh, he says in a talking head as he's leaving, there's this line where he said,
是的！我的意思是，他发表了这样一个巨大的演讲，基本上他说：“我要辞职，所以我辞职了。”是的，他辞职了。为了不泄露他和安吉拉的关系以及他今天早上去了哪里的秘密，他辞职了。德怀特离开了。他把他的东西盒子给了迈克尔。他确实留下了他的德怀特摇头娃娃。我告诉你。当然。有一个删减片段，他走来走去，把盒子里的东西分给我们所有人。珍娜，这很有趣。我记得拍过那个。是的。然后他走出去，行了他的礼。那是和入职时一样的礼。不错的致敬。德怀特走了。是的。安吉拉，他有一句台词，天哪，他在离开时对着镜头说，有句台词他说，
I really believed I was going to die in that chair. That he was so committed to Dunder Mifflin, he thought he would die in his sales chair. I mean, oh, I have no doubt that's ultimately how it ends for Dwight someday. If the series would have gone. Yeah, in fan fiction, if you write the end. I see Dwight's funeral like, you know, have you ever heard of these funeral homes that would stage family members doing their favorite activity?
“我真的相信我会死在那把椅子上。”他如此忠于邓德·米福林，他以为他会死在他的销售椅上。我的意思是，哦，我毫不怀疑这最终就是德怀特某天结局的方式。如果剧集继续下去的话。是的，在同人小说里，如果你写结局的话。我看到德怀特的葬礼就像，你知道，你听说过这些殡仪馆吗，他们会安排家庭成员做他们最喜欢的活动？
No, I have never, I have never heard of a funeral where a person is staged doing their favorite activity. So like, for example, if you love fishing, since we've been talking about fishing, the person would be staged like in a boat with a fishing rod? Yes, I saw a show, I saw a show all about it, don't ask me, I think I was like just channel surfing,
不，我从来没听说过葬礼上一个人被摆成做他最喜欢的活动的样子。所以，例如，如果你喜欢钓鱼，既然我们一直在谈论钓鱼，那个人会被摆成在船上拿着鱼竿的样子？是的，我看过一个节目，我看过一个关于它的节目，别问我，我想我当时只是在换台，
looking for something. But like, it's like a thing you can get and they have devices that prop people up and things. But like, let's say you love surfing, you'd be posed on your surfboard. It's a real thing. And then instead of like awake where they come and view the body
找点什么看。但就像，这是一种你可以得到的东西，他们有装置把人支撑起来之类的。但假设你喜欢冲浪，你会摆在你的冲浪板上。这是真实存在的。然后不是像守灵那样，他们来瞻仰遗体，
and you're in the casket, like, and you say your goodbye, you're on your surfboard. Well, if it were me, I guess I would be propped up maybe watching TV, eating a bowl of frozen yogurt or making bread. And you can come say goodbye to me. I'd be, you know, hanging my hummingbird feeder
你在棺材里，然后你告别，你是在你的冲浪板上。嗯，如果是我，我想我会摆成可能在看电视，吃一碗冷冻酸奶或者做面包的样子。你可以来跟我告别。我会，你知道，挂着我的蜂鸟喂食器，
and holding a glass of wine, I guess. Oh, Angela, now I want this for your funeral. If I outlive you, if I outlive you, I am gonna pose you with a hummingbird feeder in one hand and a glass of rosé in the other and I'm gonna come say goodbye to you. I will talk to you for hours. Please have it be a real hummingbird feeder with real hummingbird food and maybe they'll come take
手里拿着一杯酒，我想。哦，安吉拉，现在我想要这个作为你的葬礼。如果我比你活得长，如果我比你活得长，我会让你一只手拿着蜂鸟喂食器，另一只手拿着一杯桃红葡萄酒，我会来跟你告别。我会跟你聊上几个小时。请一定要用真正的蜂鸟喂食器，里面有真正的蜂鸟食物，也许我站在那里的时候它们会来喝一口。哦，拜托。好的。说定了。所以是的。我想你的意思是，也许德怀特的葬礼上他会被摆在他的邓德·米福林办公桌前。好的。接一个销售电话。哇。在殡仪馆，甚至有一本你可以翻阅的样册。哦，是的，我会选展品A，在桌前打字的姿势。
a drink while I'm standing there. Oh please. Okay. Done and done. So yes. I guess your point was that perhaps Dwight's funeral he would have been staged at his Dunder Mifflin desk. Okay. Taking a sales call. Wow. At the funeral home, there's even a look book that you can flip through. Oh yeah, I'll take exhibit A at the desk typing on the keyboard pose.
哇。我觉得你可以用这个做一些真正的被动攻击的事情。就像谁负责你的葬礼。就像你可以做一些真正的被动攻击的事情，就像谁负责你的葬礼，你可以说：“哦，你想知道拉里最喜欢的活动吗？我告诉你那是什么，那是玛乔丽，所以我让他摆成拿着他的……”天哪，为什么这让我笑得这么厉害？就像人们来参加葬礼时，他们会说：“这是怎么回事？”
Wow. I feel like you could do some real passive aggressive stuff with this. Like whoever is in charge of your funeral. like you could do some real passive aggressive stuff with this like whoever is in charge of your funeral you could be like oh you want to know Larry's favorite activity I'll tell you what it was it was Marjorie so I posed him holding his. Oh my God, why is that cracking me up so much? It'd be like when people come for the funeral, they're like, what is going on?
我们说：“拉里的最爱活动。在网上当玛乔丽的舔狗。”是的，所以那是玛乔丽在电脑上的照片。那是他拿着一个……我花了5000美元买这个。去你的，拉里。天哪。
And we're like, Larry's favorite activity. Being a f***** to Marjorie online. Yeah. So that's Marjorie's picture on the computer. That's him holding a shmingy. I paid $5,000 for this. F*** you, Larry. Oh my God.
天哪。好的，听着。与此同时，玛乔丽说：“我不知道有人知道。”天哪。好的，听着。玛乔丽，与此同时玛乔丽说：“我不知道有人知道。”我，天哪。我不知道。天哪，玛乔丽的丈夫乔超级震惊。他说：“玛吉，怎么了？”嘿，这一切都在Lifetime的《洗衣与背叛》里。
Oh my goodness. Okay, listen. Meanwhile, Marjorie's like, I didn't know anyone knew. Oh my goodness. Okay, listen. And Marjorie, meanwhile Marjorie's like, I didn't know anyone knew. I, oh my God. I did not. My God, Marjorie's husband, Joe is like super shocked. He's like Marge, what's? Hey, it's all in laundry and betrayal on Lifetime.
我们刚写好剧本，女士。葬礼上的大揭秘。好的。我们刚写好剧本，女士。葬礼上的大揭秘。好的。好的。好的。所以现在，现在我们有这个精彩的，我们得振作起来。好的。天哪。好的。
We just wrote our script, lady. The big reveal at the funeral. Okay. We just wrote our script, lady. The big reveal at the funeral. OK. OK. OK. So now, now we have this amazing, we have to get it together. OK. Oh my God. OK.
现在我们有这个精彩的安迪独白。这是对《威利·旺卡》的致敬。太棒了。它听起来有点像“奥姆帕·隆帕，迪皮蒂·多萨姆。德怀特现在走了，这太棒了。”是的。我当时想，谁写的这个独白？谁写的？太好了。在DVD评论里，他们说是迈克·舒尔。
Now we have this amazing Andy talking head. It's a Willy Wonka callback. It's awesome. It goes a little something like oompa loompa dippity dosum. Dwight is now gone, which is totally awesome. Yeah. I was like, who wrote this talking head? Who wrote this? So good. And in the DVD commentary, they said it was Mike Schur.
哦，原来如此。是的。埃德说迈克在他做独白时就在房间里，他们即兴发挥，找到了这一段，太完美了。然后当然，安吉拉，在这个独白的背景里，镜头发现你在背景里徘徊，投射出死亡凝视。哦，是的，死亡凝视。我记得太清楚了。所以格雷格说：“安吉拉，我真的希望你瞪眼，就像真的非常生气。”
Oh, there you go. Yeah. Ed said that Mike was in the room with him when he was doing his talking head and they were riffing around and they found this one and it's so perfect. And then of course Angela in the background of this talking head the camera finds you hovering in the background giving a death stare. Oh yeah, death stare. I remember this so vividly. So Greg was like, Angela, I really want you to glare, like really be angry.
就像安迪要倒霉了，你恨他，瞪着他。所以我做了。他走到我面前说：“你能再多给点吗？”我说：“什么？”他说：“更狠一点。我需要所有死亡凝视中的死亡凝视。”我又做了一次。他说：“安吉拉，再多一点。”我在日记里写了这件事。我说：“格雷格一直说，再来一次，安吉拉，更生气，更多。”到最后，我的眼球在头里颤抖。
Just like Andy is going down, you hate him, glare at him. So I did. And he came up to me and he was like, can you give me more? I was like, what? He was like, even harder. I want you to, I just need the death stare of all death stares. I did it again. He's like, Angela, even more. I wrote about it in my journal. I said, Greg kept saying, one more time, Angela, more mad, more. By the end, my eyeballs were shaking in my head.
我写下：“安吉拉，你头疼了吗？”是的，我留着科幻发髻。我正在进行超级死亡凝视。真的到最后，我想你可以极其轻微地看到我在颤抖。我的凝视就是那么愤怒，以至于我……我很好奇你是不是在眼球里爆了血管之类的。它太强烈了。我当时正要……就像在眼球里爆了血管之类的。
I wrote down, Angela, did you get a headache? Yes, I had the sci-fi bun. I was giving the super death stare. And truly by the end, I think you can ever so slightly see me shaking. That's how like angry my stare is that I'm like. I was curious if you like popped a blood vessel in your eyeball or something. It is so intense. I was about to, like popped a blood vessel in your eyeball or something.
它太强烈了。我当时正要。我不开玩笑。这是结束这一集的绝佳方式。我有一个粉丝问题，安吉拉。好的。我不是想拆解这部剧的整个情节。什么？
It is so intense. I was about to. I'm not kidding. It is a great way to end the episode. I do have a fan question, Angela. Okay. And I don't mean to unravel the entire plot of this show. What?
但这是一个好问题。好的。它来自格蕾丝·D，她说：“为什么安吉拉不能自己把税表带到总部？”她猫太多了，格蕾丝。嗯，而且我们也从删减片段里知道，她的一只猫刚生了一窝小猫，她正在处理。那也是我的第一个想法，安吉拉。起初我被那个难住了。我想：“是的，为什么安吉拉不自己去纽约？”但后来我想：“不，她可能有……”
But it's a good question. Okay. It comes from Grace D and she says, why couldn't Angela just bring her own tax forms to corporate? She has too many cats, Grace. Well, and also we know from the deleted scenes, some one of her cats just had a litter of kittens that she's dealing with. That was my first thought too, Angela. I was kind of stumped by that at first. And I was like, yeah, why didn't Angela just go to New York herself? But then I was like, no, she probably has,
她可能起得很早，每天早上都有一个90分钟的猫咪例行公事要做。给眼睛涂药膏、喂药和梳理毛发，对吧？是的，准备好一天的猫砂盆，给它们所有人放好食物。我想她在上班前有一个完整的早晨，特别是如果她有一窝小猫的话。我想她可能压力很大，正在和德怀特过这份清单，他只是说：“我带去，别担心。”
she probably gets up very early and has like a 90 minute cat routine she has to do every morning. Putting ointment on eyes and medicines and grooming right? Yes and getting the litter boxes ready for the day and setting out food for all of them I think she has a full morning before she gets to work and especially if she had a litter of kittens and I think she was probably stressing out and going through this whole list with Dwight and he just said I'll take them don't worry
“我会做的，我会做的。”是的，没错，德怀特的选择是带表格去纽约还是做护理清单。他说：“我选择带表格去纽约。”是的。但好问题，格蕾丝。我觉得是个有效的问题。有效的问题。嗯，女士，这就是《出差销售员》。下周我们将进入《回归》。是的，《回归》是几个人的回归。这是一集非常有趣的剧集。所以我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。
I'll do it I'll do it. Yes that's right the choices with Dwight and he just said, I'll take them. Don't worry. I'll do it. I'll do it. Yes, that's right. The choices for Dwight were take the forms to New York or do the care list. And he was like, I choose forms to New York. Yeah. But good question, Grace. I thought valid question. Valid question. Well, lady, that is Traveling Salesman. Next week we head into The Return. Yes, and The Return is the return for several people. And it's such a fun episode. So we will see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf.
《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·乔金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由Odyssey呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·乔金斯，我们的音频工程师兼助理制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿演唱的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。